[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for a week
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
live apologies y'all
[Laughter]
welcome to the iron lord podcast and
also live on lords of gaming.net episode
number 184 and it's another glorious
sunday we're back at the round table on
the lord's day
i'm very excited about our special guest
and we've got the next generation launch
week special to discuss so we gonna get
right into it
i want to introduce the lord whose
consistent support within the realm is
not only humbling to the ilp but has
also built his own platform into a haven
where varied opinions can engage in
healthy discourse and spicy debate
introducing the creating host of the
basement radio arcade podcast
the overly proud member of pc master
race
legend of ric flair beams and
affectionately noted the realm as lord
chancleta himself
live from the dmv and making his return
into the realm of the lords
my man lord enrique aka brat podcast how
are you doing sir
that's problem
next gen is here
and uh all i gotta say is pcmr though
yeah okay okay
no it's it's great to be back it's a
stack panel of guests we got aids clowns
kid uh this is gonna be a great show and
look i'm just i'm excited that uh
considering these crazy times we're
living in right now that we have one
beacon of positivity and hope and that's
these next-gen consoles so it's going to
be a great show absolutely absolutely
you know we're gonna get into it man
good to have you and of course we have a
lord who needs no formal introduction in
the realm of the iop and has been an
amazing ally since its very inception
whether it be his supreme passion for
the xbox brand or entertaining live
streams all done with that trademark
introducing the creator of the kidsmove
youtube channel host of planet xbox and
a panelist of the weapon wheel podcast
the self-proclaimed best bot
and by far the most hilarious streamer
with the dual sets controller in here
live from new jerusalem and making his
return into the realm of the lords
my man lord kids move how we doing sir
doing awesome night wow these are
oh man shut up shout out yo adding i
need you to get these super chats man i
don't want to get too far behind i think
we got the inseparate ghost that was one
and we got stitch i believe if you want
to get those to soft sadly behind it
yeah i'll get them for now while you get
ready so shout out to stage for the
twizzle chat car can you add profit to
oh yeah we already do that your king's
coming and we relax relax
shout out to the assembly goats luke
lord 2000 chat next gen is looking good
even though by tcl
salute
you know but kate what's going on cam
i mean i'm i'm doing good i mean i'm i'm
just super excited um overwhelmed
honestly dude like with
all the like the games and new stuff i
had there's like there's games i haven't
even touched yet but dude i'm hyped
um i've been trying to lay low on
twitter so you haven't seen the banter
from me yes yes you've been behaving
yeah i've been doing my like my low-key
but dude yeah i i just can't wait it's
exciting times man exciting times happy
to see everybody you know getting their
stuff on twitter people showing your
consoles gameplay everybody's here um
it's awesome man
can't complain right now already no good
to have you back man it's been a minute
and of course we have a lord whose
platform not only accomplishes the
epitome of journalistic professionalism
but whose podcast also represents a
breath of fresh air from platform
toxicity
introducing the president and founder of
seasongaming.com
and the host of the big cast on youtube
my fellow sega bredrin
staunch defender of mass effect 1 and
final fantasy 6
and honorable mention for king of the
statues
live from kc and making his return into
the realm of the lords
my man lord aysley bowden how are we
doing sir
what is going on guys good morning i
think uh diego uh named me prince of the
statues which is fine you know i like
that
i could take that that's fine
i can see that statue on the side of you
though let them see
[Laughter]
i'm doing good guys man as these guys
said next gen is here
man in a year that's been rough top to
bottom uh it's nice for us all to be
enjoying some new [ __ ] that we've been
talking about for oh sorry we've been
talking about it for a couple years
it's okay you want to know what's dave
what are we respecting
um but no happy to be here guys always
love hanging out with you so thanks for
the invite looking forward to it much
appreciated man always good to have you
in a realm and appreciate you putting in
the triple shift of podcast
you know we go long so you know again we
respect your time you know based on the
situation
you already know you know look like we
got rake the emperor right quick shout
out to him with the father oh happy
birthday oh thank you brother lord cog
have a great birthday and be safe and
what's up with brat
no doubt and last but certainly by no
means least a true friend to the realm
whose passion for multi-platform gaming
also originates with toys r us and the
insertion of that magical arcade quarter
introducing the host of the four guys
recorders podcast and a panelist of
primetime gaming and gaming beyond the
box
everyone's favorite gaming paisan
and when it comes to not playing destiny
will make you an offer you can't refuse
from florida and making his return into
the realm of the lords
mommy
lord italian clowns how you doing sir
hey what's going on man it's a pleasure
being here first of all happy birthday
lord cognito happy birthday man thank
you bro uh awesome panel you've
assembled glad to see king feeling a
little bit better coming on here
i see he's even brought some paisans
with them behind him for backup uh super
mario back there you know in case any
baby wants to come and steal his uh 3000
ps5
uh yeah you know i'm just gonna say one
thing man if you're in florida watch out
for the babies rolling around circle k
and diapers they definitely steal stuff
like my series x i see i see you forget
the axis the babies down right in
florida
no doubt man good to have you back it's
been a minute since you've been on suns
good to have you back in the realm my
main italian clowns so normally we would
have the uh four horsepower game we are
one horseman down please we've gotta
what's up let me get this please please
please please we gotta find out from
smitty smith happy birthday to my
warlock brother lord cognito incarnation
oh my man smitty smith what's going on
yuri no cognition you know we do but um
yeah man we are down one law if he sends
some love to lord soft he's gotta do
some take care of some family business
he's okay but he's gotta take care of
some family business man so we
definitely want to shout him out you
want to get bina right quick uh addict
yeah we got a five dollar super chat
from [ __ ] eight one two seven after
last week i can have
a what wednesday again
be careful
[Laughter]
anyway
so we still got the three horsemen of
gaming you know what i'm saying my calls
with cobos my brother from another
mother the difficult game conqueror lord
of his own world and the how of the
young wolf my man lord addict how are we
doing sir
doing pretty good these are this between
the next gen hype and this new destiny
expansion man like
i'm i'm for some reason i'm not even
tired like i think i've went past not
sleeping and i've just ascended to
to a completely new realm
well i stitch got time on he [ __ ] man
i don't know what's going on
why is the time
i can't anyway but y'all you're a blazer
man they're trying to talk about this
xbox that's all they that's all they
want yeah they just want to get straight
to the small king's back they're happy
you know how that go
and speaking of which
and of course returning we have the
incredible hulk of this aka the access
gamer
the prophet of xbox
the prophet of xbox
king of the statues demands nothing less
than that premium experience it is the
leader of the fraud alert movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir
first i want to salute you and say happy
birthday brother thank you we've been on
a journey for a very long time
birthdays you know i never even thought
that we'd get to this age so it's kind
of crazy
this is beyond me um first i want to say
to all the people that wish me well uh
thank you so much um
yeah uh i don't believe whatever the
doctor said they said i didn't have
covert yes i did he didn't care about
this i don't care what they're saying
right now i was dead dying and dying
some more so um
out of control yeah
it's absolutely nuts you guys be safe
out there
um but you know to the true inspirations
you know people that are dealing with
real serious stuff like i dizzy like the
um the wise gamer oh shout out we gotta
shout out buddha uh buddha time man yeah
one time he hit me up too
you know
you know these dudes is really dealing
with real serious stuff in his life and
they still find time to game and live
joely so you know shout out to them um
kos is going to go up i know i've been
on addict addict's been helping me with
some stuff so that kos would go up
that's craving the hunter right there i
got a hell of a glory that's going to
hit that but that that's xm studios
crepe and hunter that's lion is
absolutely immense
um
this week what i've been doing well if
you have been following my twitter line
i see you shaming the devil for people
who didn't have their console sir yeah
well you know if you couldn't get a
console shame on you that's your
business
oh well and i sold all of mines today
and i didn't sell any of my x's why
because the premium product never leaves
the home
but that other product is still here
so so it is what it is we're going to
get it to that too uh
listen man y'all guys want this smoke
you can get every last drop of that
today lord we saw the priest
already know what the hell i'm in for
now jesus
knew what it was as soon as my mom's
morale is cut off
we will get into the impression soon
yes good evening gotta find out from
elemental po happy birthday cog uh
dedicate this song not like this i wish
raindrops would fall oh the heartbeats
you got to put some soul on that addict
you gotta put something
so numb but i don't know it
nights like this
y'all gotta
everything everything on my um on my
actually gonna get into the impressions
of that and then i've been playing the
only one game that i said i was buying
for that playstation crap station five
uh the miles morales that's it okay
so we got two super chats we got a five
dollar stretch i'm from jonathan b
great to see you back king but mario is
wild and homie homies looking mad evil
back there
i didn't even see where he is today i'll
have to look here in a minute we gotta
find out from j dub as a shell
oh my god no jesus for glasses i think
his beer could use a trim kind of hard
to walk on water with a heavy beard
savage let me get boogie back
thank you yes i spent five hours with
you i spent 17 hours in line for my
series x to get it well worth it happy
birthday [ __ ] thank you brother glad
you're able to live long and prosper
king you know what i'm saying so silly
around 17 too man i feel you man we got
a five dollar super chat from squirrely
it's girly uh
i ain't that's all you man yeah call the
fire department your department's gonna
burn it down get down happy birthday my
man called oh it's a little squirrel
yeah mischie um your xbox live party
chat that night i was a little busy
about sword afterwards but salute to you
squirrely you already know and of course
we have the gaming ninja himself happy
boy nate to myself
the shinobi unlocked laura cognito
spreading that realism around the iop
not telling what you want to hear but
what you need to hear man so it's been
definitely a fun week next gen consoles
we're gonna get into everything um yeah
magic's vacation right into the
birthdays the best two weeks off so far
and i'm enjoying it still so much to do
man so not not a lot of destiny but
there's really been playing a lot of the
other games so um last word we'll
probably come back this friday so also
like we said earlier send some positive
vibes out to everybody community again i
brought the buddha time you know wise
old gamer you know what i'm saying
people going through it right now so
we're good to see them they're both
recovering from some situations no last
week's poll because i forgot to put it
up after jay serrano
so we will uh we'll do a new one we'll
do a new one this week but we're gonna
get this thing rocking man because kid i
see drop but hopefully can we get kid
back because i want to get him in on the
first topic um get that get somebody
smith real quick off at it and then
we'll jump just get up rolling all right
we got a two dollars per chat from
smitty smith no more wait until orbit
series x whoa
that's true that is true that is true so
look
next gen has arrived both consoles
they're here you know saying the long
wait is we're going for oh yeah yeah get
super gay yeah
87. definitely put those put those logos
in that chat man put those logos in that
chat right welcome yeah
let me get this
oh you got it
we gotta find out your
i need answers both rocket leader and
warzone card are both running at 120
frames on the series x and 60 frames on
the ps5 we'll get
i already see what's going on so kiss
both are you back sir just want to make
sure because i want to set it off with
you i know your time is limited
yeah yeah i'm back and i i
entered my job and the wi-fi kicking
knocked me out
shout out to the job wi-fi salute be
careful
david flay shout out the hud zero five
triple happy for the people was able to
get this series x and ps5 even happier i
was waiting for the bugs to get ironed
out stick with my one x for now and you
want to get uh oh damn pixel bit five
y'all thank you brother happy birthday
[ __ ] welcome back king big up to the
additions to today's panel welcome to
the next gen let's go who did that for
you okay okay
from stitch this is why i am here
smoking like i total cog i hope kids are
not asking for santa for a ps4 because
that's how long it took that's how long
they finding santa ain't real savage oh
let me get boom happy birthday
happy birthday cog welcome back kig glad
you are well welcome pocket watching
playstation 5's breaking down yo y'all
messy today shout out to boom that's all
right boom we know what it is oh my god
here we go can we really say they're
wrong though moving along they're wrong
listen i got brad we're about to get the
smoke on right now
we are good
anyway little kiss move man next jet is
upon us man so i just wanted to set it
off with you i know you're time limited
but um just your experience securing it
how was that and then you know any i
know you did an unboxing you know what
i'm saying or whatever so both consoles
are here how was this week give me your
experiences man
bro let's once again it's been
overwhelming um i'll tell you about my
pre-order um process really quick um
obviously i uh was unable to secure a
playstation 5 pre-order because we know
how that went down it happened while
that worked
and i could when i rushed into gamestop
i already seen
like when i looked at the line at
gamestop i'm like yeah i ain't making it
so um
obviously xbox came through i was able
to secure mine from microsoft.com like
soon as like 11 o'clock hit and then i
ran over to gamestop in my town to
secure
um the series s so i was able to
successfully secure both xboxes on the
day they pre-ordered it nice
shout out to lord blandrew he came
through he had a um he's not really
messing with playstation like that so he
pre-ordered one and he's and he sold it
to me at marquee i didn't wow
shout out to black switch gang in the
house that's what's up coming out
is that so he sent that over to me it
got to me day one um but i had to do
small talk with the ups guy so that he
can give it to me small talk
yeah because he felt
he needed to put the all the packages
right on top of my playstation box in
their in their respectful boxes instead
of just looking down and seeing my name
and giving it to me so he wanted to
engage in small talk so i'm like yeah
bro i was like
i'm not in the booth but if this is what
i gotta do to get the freedom
[Laughter]
[Music]
when when the xbox uh came through and
opening the box for the first time
um
it was just a certain feeling that ran
through my nerves
and i'm like yo
this is it and then opening the box and
seeing the way that it's like looking at
you
it's kind of fun that power your dreams
packaging premium yeah
right and picking it up and looking at
it and the crazy thing is all these
unboxing videos we've seen and preview
coverage it still to me was smaller than
i anticipated right yep
yes
it it it feels it's like i sit on my
desk i just stare at it
the monolith
yeah it's cool and then the series s
like um it's just it's a little cute
console man um i played on it a little
bit um i i i i bent the knee on that
expansions
you did it you did it
you know i got four oh my god it's worse
than it sounds he what he did is he
traded his xbox one x4 oh my god you
gave me the castle [ __ ] jesus
yeah bro
somebody was supposed to buy my one x
right they fell through and i walked in
the game stop and i'm like
and i'm looking down
they got the game stop telling you this
is what the clerk said he was like well
you got the one x oh yeah you know he
said he said you got this series x you
got the series that's i mean do you
really need your money well he is right
about yeah yeah i just don't get that
i was like do you want to buy it from me
and he was like no no i'm just saying
you know i got this one last speech you
passed
you said you could trade it really
yeah they gave you two hundred dollars
it was a good deal
and i got it bro the size difference
between a one x and this little ssd i
was i couldn't believe i traded my xbox
one
wow that is that puts it in perspective
that is interesting right crazy dude so
and of course gamestop they sent me a
wrong controller i ordered uh um
a white one they sent me an additional
black one which is fine i just bought it
to gamestop and exchanged it for that
sonic blue one that shot blue oh yeah
yeah yeah that's nice that's nice look
let's get the super chat that will
actually playstation
yeah so we got to tell super chat from
italian clowns our very own on the
podcast thank you happy birthday cog all
held the king so he was not ready for
next gen one dollar gameplay
with no uh database uh rebuilding never
bet against king you know what's funny
is uh my uh i couldn't get
the
the i didn't know that you had to
manually upload certain saves
onto the platform because i wanted to
keep my persona so i literally
subscribed to playstation now thinking i
was good you know what i'm saying and
then or cognito calls me he's like well
how do i get that i was like i think you
have to do it manually
yeah yeah i learned your painful lesson
let's get into that oh let's get our
gamers play zero um oh happy birthday
thank you brother he's like keep it
gaming super gav thank you very happy
boring day you know what i'm saying and
he said oh my god crap 65 that is all
hashtag these y'all messy you want to
get a dead oh sir
yeah we got a five dollar subject from
daniel glad to see you feeling better
king added great job and bearing the
weight outside for the eggs
oh yeah
from a fellow world like happy birthday
oh we're waiting on that trade i'm
trying to put the paperwork through
it's
i put destiny too and i installed it i
started playing it the other day now
first of all we don't need to get into
it right now but why the hell when i
start destiny 2 now am i playing destiny
1 from 20 30. listen man we giving you
the star just stop complaining
[Laughter]
just just to throw this out there they
locate located with a strike from d1 and
just listen
you can't complain 3.99 pass all over
here
[Laughter]
we'll get we'll get to it though we'll
get to it we'll get to it shout out uh
i can't pronounce it like soft so smooth
person that saw usually pronounces was
like louise or i don't know man i
apologize you have to just get over that
next week stop got your back right xx
was in checkout and still couldn't get
it
and the ex item yeah yeah and shout out
to hot boy hot boy i can't uh hot boy d
wow three dollar super chat hashtag kiss
move 2024 so kid yeah finish up um
playstation experience also i wanted to
know how that went yeah yeah so
playstation um
like i said that was
even bigger than what i anticipated um
me and attic
was having this conversation in the dms
um like when it was like like i think
those week photos came out and i was
like that's not real and he was like
he's like no i think it's really [ __ ]
over there he fought me i fought him
over there and i'm like oh yeah he's
he was absent that that is actually that
big mom the first thing my wife said
she's like
she's like what is that she's like that
doesn't look good on your desk it's so
ugly she was like
she looks like she was like is it like
like it must be powerful for it to be
that big and i'm like
oh that was like well obey
you see this little small black box here
yo smooth they said if there's any way
you could turn up or get it closer they
dying to hate it they said you said
you're coming
your mic is low yeah i don't know i know
you're in a probably remote situation
but if you can
let me know if i'm better because i'm
trying to figure out i mean if not look
it is what it is we know you're working
remote bro we know just keep going you
gotta kill me you gotta see me though i
hear you that you are a little louder
now yeah keep talking okay you're good
all right
so my wife thought the playstation was
ugly it it does take up a lot of real
estate on my desk like to the point
where i'm trying to adjust it so it
won't get in the way of like the monitor
and stuff like that but overall i mean
knocking on wood i am not having any
like you know technical issues uh it's
running fine quiet nice i've played uh
spider-man and um astrobot i mean
astrobots cool it's like the killer app
for controller um yes
and um spider-man i mean i tried the i
sprint booted up the game in fidelity
mode um looks cool but it's overrated so
i went into performance mode and i'm
much more comfortable with the the feel
of that yes but overall it's been fine i
mean the ui is cool it's clean and sleek
i like the things that they do with it
um however there's some things that they
change where i feel like i'm i'm working
harder
to get to certain things that i need to
get to right from the ps4 so i just
assumed it would be like something
similar it just looks different right
but it wasn't like you like your friends
aren't like you know front and center
and i had to like find where to uh where
to go to see my friends and stuff like
that um i don't notice when i get a
trophy i have to look on the screen
because the sound isn't uh hopefully you
can edit that right um but um overall
it's cool i like the controller it's
comfortable um um
i'm enjoying spider-man um i only have
like i think three games downloaded no
four games i download dave's going to
try that and not bro that's 60. that's
60 bro
hit differently definitely going to
finish that game uh sometime within the
next three months um
and so my day's gone uh astral by
spider-man and i'm pretty sure i didn't
stop buzzing i i just might understand i
don't see myself playing
can i ask you guys a question real quick
i just saw christopher hart shout out to
him in the chat he said i quote let me
let me get up there get his exact order
because you know how christopher hart is
yeah he said uh i'm too busy enjoying my
playstation that wasn't what he said he
said let me say this the ps5 is not as
big as i thought for what people were
saying how big do people it's like
it's huge like if you thought it was
bigger what oh my god like was it like
the size of the empire state building to
some of you yeah
i don't even like the way it looks in my
entertainment stand i would say yeah
yeah i put it on his side my boy called
me on the phone and said is this
supposed to lay down like that he called
me on the phone
and said is it supposed to lay down like
that
in
shout out to john on xbox live he was uh
i was showing him pictures of like it's
sitting in place he's like
is it supposed to sit sideways like that
and i was like john look how big it is
there's not much options you have like
ridiculous it no it's big let's be real
this this joke was big this thing looks
like a giant burrito i mean it's big
it's definitely gonna get that and rat's
crushing for kicks i know again his time
is limited which i get the most out of
him um gotta ask the magical question oh
yeah paul
oh vertical or horizontal life for both
they're both vertical okay okay okay all
right i respect that i respect that
that's the only answer
i thought
when i didn't upload any like of my like
saves yeah i was meeting you with both
bro
let's just point out how easy that is on
xbox but we're not going to go into that
stop
but how to all right just a couple of
things on the xbox side and king because
you said you got uh both the consoles
and you got those expansion passes right
personally i haven't installed not one
game on the series s
i've been installing every game to the
expansion pass so that when i'm
switching between i'm just oh you're
just moving back and forth right okay
it's dude i've tried that like when i
started i streamed from the series of s
i'm like you know what let me take a
couple games over there right quick and
let me see um how this game works right
so cuz you know the series that you know
has that you know 360 like some odd gigs
but yeah i'm not even going to ever like
even touch those gigs that expansion
pass is clutch and moving games yeah
from like the to that expansion passing
into your internal i was i did a video
of me moving a bunch of games and like
the video was like less than two minutes
wow wow yeah the speed of the game is
very very very fast yeah very fast let
me get the uh black prodigy files from
chat um thank you brother beta station
five oh my god
it's backed up yeah they stepped up
except
except external storage bozo jesus
prodigy
get the wise old game of it so my boys
playing astrobot and i could feel my
diabetes getting worse
i'm gonna play it when i get home
despite the insulin injections i'm gonna
need bro we salute you for being we know
what you're going through wise old gamer
appreciate jose and then i'll give it
one next one at it josette rivera lady
boom salute with the toyota super chat
happy birthday cognito fellow scorpio
may you have many more glad you're doing
well king have a great day all regards
miss boom salute thank you yes lady jose
it's amazing
you want to get uh jean-marc louis
john mccallum
that's how i solved it
playstation 5 is literally the elephant
in the room
sorry that's pretty that's pretty much
it or any other um observations for your
whole launch thing in general your
impressions in general you're pretty
much good
now now i'm pretty much good this is
also just a reminder for those um
because a lot of us already came from
like the xbox one x and s and we
probably had external hard drives
plugged in um
when you do the mistake i made was i
assumed that moving all my games to this
external um um
hard drive and then plugging it into my
series x it would just like you know
update it to the proper one right what
happens is you just get prompted that it
upgrades available and this is without
the proper one to your hard drive yeah
so when you have these hard drives
plugged in once you upgrade all those
games delete the original ones because
you're not going to need them in fact it
may cause confusion to the xbox trying
one day because watchdogs kept prompting
me to update several times even though i
already had it updated but i still had
one sitting on my external plugged in so
just delete delete any game that has an
upgrade just delete the original source
one on your external or whatever
i mean you should be good but overall
it's been smooth sailing bro no doubt no
doubt that's what's up man shout out the
eagles fan 765 today i opened a package
that was a treasure chest and saw the
quality and care put into everything the
meal was well cooked and the recipe
tasted great all right he definitely
wasn't talking about the place oh my god
y'all messy moving on
together that's a mcdonald's uh happy
meal
let me let's let's talk to some
greatness in here what's up brad
you got that you was able to secure both
right
yeah yeah i got both all right cool so
let's talk about hold up hold up
oh brother here we go now brett explain
to me
how you got both when you've been
telling you've been you've been on a
rant
for like it feels like decades now that
you weren't getting an xbox day one um
yeah this is this the stage is yours oh
my god this is what this is i mean i
just went out and got one
we just got to go with that all right
that's cool man that's fine that's why i
know yeah
anyway
yeah
well feel dominance maximus are really
expensive we want to bend the knees
shout out
you definitely bent the knee brad we
can't act like we just hear this let me
just share the story though we we had
lord king on brap when uh the whole uh
bethesda announcement had happened i
shared this story with you yes
you know uh a king had a way of of just
i don't know it's just very persuasive
he said to me
after we went off air king i think took
off his shades yes looked at me the
camera said brad
isn't your kid worth
that 35 dollars a month for the xbox
live i remember this and i was like yo i
was like i was like
what can i say i mean you can't say no
yeah that's really good that's real i
respect bad you got you got your balls
you made brat bend the knee how you feel
no no it wasn't even about that it's
about having real conversations in the
background uh you know behind the hype
and bull you know um real conversations
is this all right i can hear if you say
that's not your cup of tea and that's
not something that you game on he games
on pc right but literally his son wanted
uh x or wanted um
yeah they were a console
they wanted it right so if you if you
break it down
the the pennies on a dollar to get his
son that plus all those games and game
pass which on november 10th
exponentially grew in value once they
put ea game pass in there
yeah he saved way more money by spending
the 35 a month his son is super happy he
has all these games and i'm pretty sure
that he doesn't have to worry about
buying games for the next four years
yeah no it's funny you mentioned that
king because uh one of the things that
we're worried about like well what about
the games that we downloaded or they got
like nope they're not gone you have them
still so they you see the like their
faces light up like oh that's great um
but actually what i ended up doing was
trading in what'd you do uh i traded in
uh i went to gamestop traded in my 1x
got that 200 dollar trading value
beautiful beautiful trading trading my
games for look for both consoles i paid
526 for both consoles with trading oh
dude that's impressive
with the warranties by the way
you got the two years right yeah two
years gotta go you gotta get the
warranty fast these councils were gonna
have issues that launched boom
they were killing me when i did that i
remember i put my receipt they were like
you bought a warranty for i'm like yes
with these consoles i don't know what's
going on continue yo you have to i mean
we're seeing issues um on the
playstation 5 we're seeing issues on the
xbox uh series x i mean there's going to
be launch day issues it's going to
happen it happens every every launch but
um
yeah so no i you know i got both at
launch um
you know i will say this uh the xbox
series x in my opinion you have to stand
it vertical to me that's where it look
how it looks best i wish i could i wish
i could do that continue gotcha yeah you
know you have to do it
and i mean
arranged his game room so he could stand
it vertically listen
you can't take what ainsley is saying
ainsley has a whole house
yeah dude
that's what i'm saying like ainsley has
a gym
his gaming area is literally people's
houses
you get invited one day but the point is
the point is you got to do what you got
to do to make it work
is the only option
i see i see that cyberpunk chairs
looking real nice too because yeah yeah
you heard what they said about the seven
[ __ ] good guys at the cyber [ __ ]
[ __ ]
go pay him no mind with the 700
excitement
[Laughter]
you know i could say that because i went
to go get this cyberpunk tree i was like
oh ants did the unboxing he was talking
about all the wood grain and it's
beautiful with the leathery grain and
the breathable and i was like oh let me
get this let me oh
[Laughter]
just like the experience of both you
know
boxing the whole bit keep on man how's
your experience well um i know we talked
about uh i think kid brought off the
boxes yeah i mean definitely the
boxing's a little more uh heavy duty i
guess but yeah for the xbox yeah i would
like to use the words premium and yeah
look like it's funny when the guy gave
me the playstation 5 and i'm like wait a
minute this box is a little flimsy and
i'm like is this is this going to hold i
was yo i was holding with all right one
hand at the bottom yeah one hand at the
top because let me ask you this bra
now you got yours from gamestop baby
snap yeah yo how they gonna do you did
they give you a bag i was gonna ask you
this no no they couldn't you guys like
the bag won't fit over the playstation
they give you the code
you know what's funny uh when i picked
up the series x because ours was in
black bags because you know xbox series
x's can fit in bags but we're gonna go
into that but um
so when i got that i picked it up i was
like yo this this could be a workout
this thing is heavy yeah you know what's
funny uh that you say that attic when i
picked up the box guy gave me this the
series x i i wasn't expecting it to be
that heavy yeah but it was i was like oh
this is a little babies it's definitely
yeah yeah yeah the playstation 5 yeah
you know so uh has has weighed in
yeah
yeah no i'll tell you so so you know the
the one thing that um with the series x
was i that really impressed me was how
easy was
to set up the console using that app i'm
like what yeah big time like this is
great like this is like you know just
pull up my xbox app select everything
i'm good everything just
it synced all my data all my information
all my save so seamless
it was amazing and then
you know the the first game i played on
the series x was the assassin's creed
valhalla um and the first thing i mean
those was the higher frames i mean
that's
yeah you know it was nice to play a
console and actually fill that because
like i was ignorant before i went to pc
but i'm no longer ignorant i can tell
you we joined we joined rap with that
well i mean you know and it's great uh
it's funny like we had uh well we did a
bra yesterday with erica uh erica's for
the win and erica was like cause i was
like yeah you know like i don't feel
like series x is like the launch of the
series is really a next-gen loss per se
but she was like yeah brad you're also
taking it from the perspective that
you've had those experiences with higher
frame i'm like and that was a great
point i'm like yeah if i remove myself
my experience in gaming like absolutely
like i've had that 60
120 144 frames per second type gaming
experience you had that ssd stuff too
yeah and i had the ssd and you know i
think for a lot of people when they fire
up the series x they play valhalla
they're gonna be like wow like this is
this is incredible like absolutely it's
it's so
noticeable yes
is and i'm just like this is great a lot
of people are going to enjoy that i
think on the series next my only my only
gripe is that we don't have
that
marquee
first party launch title that just like
wows you right i don't think we have
that from either one of them i don't
think okay let's again this is going to
be just the kind of impressions in the
setup
with the games
but overall impressions continue but
overall i think the ui it's very
familiar um you know i i i it's funny as
i was as we were talking more about the
uis on bra yesterday and i was thinking
about like i like that playstation 5
upgraded the ui but then there's some
there's some quality of life things that
are missing from the playstation 5 ui
like this like to get you your friend's
list just seems a little hundred
conversations like yo like what why did
they change that i know i missed the old
bar too yeah yeah so like and my dynamic
themes like i heard you talking about
this cog
i had aeris theme song on my playstation
4 for f every time i fired up you hear
ayer's theme song kick in and that's one
of my favorite songs from any game on
final fantasy 7. by the way
let me tell you something don't let
anyone tell you final fantasy 7 final
fantasy 6 is not a good game
please don't start him up guys
one of the best villains there you go
yes
everyone said that it wasn't a good game
so you get your frogs
i'm sorry that we're comparing gold bars
and which one shines the most
continue by this the final fantasy beef
that being aids will never stop arguing
about yeah hello even dizzy's in the
chat too kafka the goat oh god yeah
yeah
continue um
but yeah so there's definitely some
quality life things that are missing
from the playstation ui don't get me
wrong like it looks like a premium like
you fire it up and forte says it's like
you see the rays coming down the ui it's
like god's shining down
this was rated down greatness radius was
really 4k hdr
it looks great but there are some
quality of life things that sony
definitely needs to improve
uh which i you know coming from the
playstation 4
to this i'm like uh yeah i like the ui
but like i'm missing those quality life
things like that there's other things on
deck that they worrying about as far as
just working so
i think those quality of life things
need to take back right now yeah they
just need to get the games to work
let's get them to work first
but but i'll say i'll also say this uh
with with the controllers for each
console uh i got that blue controller i
forget what it's called for the uh
series x crit blue
yeah
yeah
that's hilarious i was mad that they
didn't have a blood red dough i'm like
the lords do not support activity no no
no okay listen listen to what i'm saying
like usually
whatever they do anyway all right they
always have like a republican and a
democrat right you always have the blue
and red and i'm just like wow you didn't
even give me the option of having a red
so i saw a red controller that was there
right and i was about to grab it right i
was like oh i'm about to go grab the red
one but it was the old school one
oh you mean that song
let
i like the improvements to the d-pad on
the xbox controller i think that's you
know i i know some people complain about
the cop how loud they even put that yeah
they even put that um that texture
pattern on the on the bumpers now so
like i can't go back to the old xbox
shows like my brother has the one that
they made last right before they went to
the series x but even that one feels
weird now no doubt continue yeah i i do
feel like it maybe the controller feels
a little bit smaller in my hands yes
yeah yeah and so i mean like that's not
a bad thing per se uh but like like
addicts say the textures on the uh on
the trigger buttons are great i love
that
uh just look is this solid control i
mean the the going into this generation
i thought the xbox controllers were
probably uh the best out there um but
that made my mind may have changed with
the playstation 5 dual sense now because
that dual sense controller i feel like
they took
the best of
what the dual shock 4 did what the xbox
controllers did kind of merge them
together the thumb sticks feel a little
bit tighter yes all the on the dual
sense and then that haptic feedback i
mean when you when you're playing i
think kids said this when you're playing
miles morales you could feel the tension
yes when you're on the webs
you could feel the weight of the guys
when you when you pick them up
you you pick them up you wrap them up in
that cocoon web and beat them up leave
them hanging there you can feel the
weight of those guys on the controller
yeah it's just it's sick man is it like
that's cool and i and i do think that
dual sense is is probably like the next
evolution in terms of features on a
controller but when i hear all that i'm
like that's just plenty of stuff to mess
up on the controller like like i i think
when when i'm like playing like destiny
or something obviously i don't play
destiny on the playstation but like when
i go to shoot i panic shoot sometimes in
trials and like
it's not going to stop me from using
that gun
like i'm going to break the controller
because i'm going to force it down
every time i hear somebody talk all that
crap about the controller how oh i feel
the tension and the wind the wind i said
i say you know i guess they don't have a
switch
um
this switch does not do that yes it does
it got to that level
yes
i was feeling the ice cubes and i was
feeling all right and i was doing all
and i was feeling the shaking and all
that i was that's old so they no no no
the tension isn't there like it is made
the technology better
yeah
yeah it's funny it's funny you mentioned
that kick because uh b money said this
uh on brap when the uh a while back when
uh the switch launch he said watch watch
people like nintendo's always go back to
the n64 right with the n64 controller
they're always like kind of leading the
charge with things like that innovations
and controllers and sony yeah to what
king said to the extent they actually
did improve upon what the switch did uh
but the switch doesn't have that kind of
tension
no it's not well what they did was they
looked at the technology and they
expanded on it like so well that's all
playstation knows how to do this yeah
that's what they do they copy and paste
and they did it better but
nintendo has always analogs from digital
pads from analog to everything they are
the innovators and they are the
beginners so
yeah of course everybody's going to keep
acting like oh my god i've never felt
this before then you never brought a
switch or you did buy a switch you
brought a standstill so
and it didn't have those features i'll
say this i i the level of tension though
that you feel on the dual sense you
don't feel that on the switch
you don't you don't feel that
it's on another level you know the first
time you you took the switch and
remember when he did the ice cubes and
see i brought all those games yeah i
brought every last one of those games
for the switch that made you feel that
wiggle wiggle and all that stuff that
was really pissed off when they made a
standstill so
when it was one game that you had to
play and it's the tension that you feel
like i couldn't push the controller
together
because for some reason they was they
wouldn't go together and i felt the
tension in between i said this is
magnificent
these dudes is onto something in such a
little form factor so
i'm not going to take away their credit
for what they did these dudes made
haptic um feedback controllers and uh
detention is good the showcase game
is the astrobot
yeah it is true we'll get to it and it
it is the best thing on um the console
is the controller yeah yeah i i i will
say this just minor complaint and and i
think i heard ayn say this on his show
yesterday uh i wish the thumbsticks uh
on the dual sense were a little more i
guess textured um you know a little more
grip to it but that that's that's
probably my only minor complaint yeah
other other than that it's to me that's
controller right now no doubt before i
get a's i'm gonna give you super chat
shout out oh man we had the wise old
game and we missed a lot at it we got to
go back up um
i was up the wise old game and then it
bumped me crazy
okay i think it here we go i used to do
it wow
i used to do it horizontally in the
family room but after my wife got
pregnant a second time oh my god hoa
complaining i had to do it vertically
thank you for sharing sir
yeah dad cunningham five dollar super
chat happy birthday thank you people
saying you spent 500 to play tetris
you're damn right better than bug snacks
on a bad day hashtag old school gameplay
okay yeah then we got eagles fans 76. yo
you said tetris
then you didn't you didn't touch that
touchdown yeah i heard his father you
know
listen if you get to have me play a
whole bunch of crap you're playing
i don't know what if i made you play
anything time
eagles fans 76
super chat thursday oh boy i should have
known from the package that meal had
rules the appetizer controller was great
the main course need to go back in the
oven okay
oh shout out to dan rodriguez the season
gaming files from chat just here to make
my monthly transfer of fronts from the
sg account to the loans also aids game
room has a game
he's getting room account credentials
revoked salute you're saying the divine
zone gave it to that super chat sony had
tcl box the pc ps5 okay oh
gerald beck finally said shout out to
the iop happy birthday carl good to see
you thank you brother king awesome panel
and i believe attica we caught up i
think michael best style he's got that
one
oh he's in the bushes accidentally okay
so i got it michael aka best uh uh [ __ ]
blue all day stop stop promoting that
sir
[Laughter]
she [ __ ] louie but let's see
i look at my 1x like it cheated on me
because of its low times can't wait for
my series x equals fan 76 again follow
super chat my god the lg cx this week
finally got that to work on spider-man
gears 5 ori at 6k super sampling and if
you don't have cx you can't explain what
you see talk that talk eagles fans
we got a two dollar super chat from cat
daddy
is the worst control i've ever used no
he said best that's not what he said
shout out to cat daddy he said the best
controller we'd be investing
let's see my man smitty smith oh file
super chat smitty smith uh dual sense is
cool but the adaptive controller is the
best where everyone can play hashtag the
book of acts i'll go within
true and then let's see um hustling
motivate
yeah that's for you attic that's how it
motivates for you
got your super chat from hustle and
motivate
don't
i can't even do it okay tell addict to
play tetris effect i'm not playing
tetris in fact we're gonna put it we're
gonna put a tear up yeah
it went listen i'll do whatever it
doesn't matter you know i don't i'm not
going to limit myself from gaming i
don't know why you're afraid of tetris
who beat you with blocks
[Laughter]
happy birthday to you all you already
know november 16th happy birthday oh
happy future birthday brother salute
salute yes yeah so look ames man let's
get right into it man again not the
games just yet just your impressions
yeah yeah yeah console the whole bit bad
both consoles next year launch yeah so
uh you know i just mentioned this on
twitter but i'm known as like the gaming
guy for family friends everyone local
right so i ended up i got five series
x's and i got four ps5s
just kind of helped a whole bunch of
people out you know getting consoles so
um got them both at launch me and dan
were like an ex a local exchange man we
had consoles all over the place nice um
you guys covered most of it man the
series x uh premium packaging premium
experience i love the console in person
it's smaller than i thought it was gonna
be yes um
it just looks like i made room ahead of
time you know how i do so i had room
ahead of time for both consoles i left
plenty of room for the ps5 knowing what
was coming
um and they're standing next to each
other and um
damn
he the only one that can say
that
he made he made expense and he told him
you're listen i want you to tear down
that wall
get ready for the playstation and for
the xbox to show and i want them to i
want them to sit uh vertical next to
each other
how many how many things ain't just six
things you know be funny
all these workers do all this work and
look it's finally done sweat pouring
down he could breathe and he just puts
them side by side and they're like you
made us do what you were
like that's that's that that's the
easiest life of ames man no no no come
on now
campaign room to uh xbox series x room
let's continue our pocket watching let's
go um yeah right right um
as long as it's not us we could pocket
exactly
the controller the emote not anyone else
continue
the um yeah ps5 is big man it's just
obnoxiously big
um every time i walk over to it it looks
like me like it's gonna take my lunch
money
um but you know
they're sitting now that they're sitting
there who cares but the series x is is
uh it's beautiful uh in my opinion
anyway it just fits with an
entertainment center you know what i
mean um set up easy on both um
you know someone mentioned i don't know
who mentioned the controller on the xbox
i'm actually surprised at how different
it feels right yeah
you know it looks the same everyone
thought it was just kind of an iteration
which it is but man it feels so much
nicer for whatever reason in your hands
i really really like it see what i don't
realize is that controller for that uh
for the xbox has been changed
probably 10 times since the xbox one
first came out
like i i dare anyone that says that the
xbox controller is the exact same
controller go get the original
controller like with the original xbox
day one and compare it to the series x
and you'll be like this is not the same
controller no way close yeah yeah
they're iterative right mm-hmm um dual
sense i'm kind of weird on the dual
sense man um so i get some of what
brad's saying my thing is like they
finally made it
for an adult
um
playstation controllers always felt
small and kind of just i never liked
them ever
um dual sense is finally a better size
it fits your hands properly which is
nice really like that's way too it
yeah yeah it just feels good i like the
way the clear buttons are and everything
that the i know we'll get into more of
the um haptics and stuff which are
really really impressive
um and i like that about it the thing
that annoys me about it though when i
ranted about this yesterday is that they
spent all this money and time and
marketing
on the new shape and the haptics and
everything but they left the triggers
and the thumb sticks the same
and it drives me crazy like those
weren't good did you think they were
good oh my god
no but they they're not they're not
they're just not good
um they're they the feel of the
thumbsticks are too slippery they're not
concave enough like there's no
competitive player
that is using standard
playstation thumbsticks it's just not
they're either doing third party
controllers on the ps4 they're putting
something on their thumbsticks um and
the triggers are just i don't know
they're just flimsy to me i i
i wish they would have spent more time
updating some of the other aspects of it
other than that i think it's it is the
best playstation controller it feels
way way better than the dualshock 4. no
no and i'm sitting here looking around
the camera because i'm looking at you
looking right at them
looking at the roof across
um no but setup setup was really good
you guys you already joked about the
packaging man i i i you guys said it i i
you get the series x especially because
it came out first right so you got the
series x and you went through all that
right and it's gorgeous and well it's
it's presented like
a microsoft product right like
you can tell microsoft and where they've
tried to go with the previous apple kind
of product presentation right that's
where they went with it right
playstation went another direction um
they they just
i king said it and i agree 100 it's like
what 500 dollar
piece of hardware have you ever seen
presented more cheaply it's bizarre to
me i don't know what they were doing
with it and it doesn't matter right it
doesn't affect playing the game or the
console it doesn't matter but it's just
weird right um
they opened a tcl up and sony was like
oh my beer i got you
and i know brad i know brad talked about
the ui um on the ps5 so it looks great i
i'm one who likes the 4k ui
it needed a redesign in my opinion i
never cared for the ps4 ui um
interesting no i just
it's it's simple and got you doing what
you wanted to do all the times of death
line of nothingness exactly yeah it was
all it was if you really examined it it
was just the ps3 ui with visuals yeah
that's all it was
um so the ps5 i like that they did the
redesign i like um sharing and
broadcasting from it's very fast i'm
doing a stream off it right now and that
interface when it pulls up you know what
i'm saying gives you the options a lot
of options there continue yeah and you
know you hit the playstation button now
and it pulls up the bottom oh it's like
the xbox slide out right it's got almost
that little guide so all of that is good
but i know uh perhaps that it is um
there there's weird things that are
missing yes um there's there's quality
of life stuff like i tried to get a
party with some friends the other night
and uh it took us like five minutes i'm
like how how the hell do i just get in a
party with friends it shouldn't be this
difficult right
um
so stuff like that i hope they iterate
because as you know like they didn't
iterate a whole lot on ps4 right they
kind of they added some features along
the way but nothing like what we saw
with xbox right so i'm hoping that um
you know in the near future here they
make some updates but overall i i those
are
what i would consider minor complaints
i'm really really happy with just having
both consoles here i've had good
experiences on both i know we're going
to get to the games and stuff
so yeah man i'm loving it and um
absolutely yeah yeah nothing else valid
valid points man i hear you lord clowns
i see your music you're still there sir
clowns might be in the bush yeah but i'm
still here no i'm here no doubt let's
get this
we got a five dollar super drive from dt
taylor i definitely probably butchered
that november 15th
we got that we got it
uh did we get the elemental p no that's
what we're up to yeah we gotta follow
the superchat from eleanor po had my s
in the bedroom so whisper quiet like my
ex placed that hand near the fan and
felt warmth
science is golden bucket s oh my gosh
let's start this
we gotta find out super chat from philly
eagle salute lords real talk anthem
still loads faster than death hey watch
your mouth
i don't know how you played that one
man i i don't think
you're wrong
holding stuff faster and anthony
do you want to see
[Music]
when you gotta treat the ps5 like it's
my 600 pound life savage
oh wow let me get this man shout out to
jansen homies out of the jazz 15 super
chat happy birthday cog this 15 is for
your birthday love conversation with you
and attic i guess king hope you feel
better salute thank you you already know
washington in the building salute we all
caught up so look clowns man i see you
back man on both systems again not the
games just the impressions your launch
feel of the week because i believe you
got you secured the digital right and as
far as the playstation 5. you're the
only person i know i think that has a
digital and did you go you went x or s
with the uh with the xbox
uh well you know the whole baby story
stole my pre-order for the x but so i
pre-ordered the s but i did some people
skills um that exhausted me throughout
the week with the gamestop manager so i
ended up getting the x anyway that's
like goomba business but continue
remember he couldn't refuse basically
you know i uh
you know what i mean so i'll feel it
you got connections in the pizza
business you know people everywhere and
uh
so i got yeah
yeah
yeah he got some pepperoni on that
i love my ex because it's just a great
experience overall you know the last for
the from the launch i walked into
gamestop uh he says don't worry we're
switching your ass for the x we're just
going to put the x aside you don't need
to camp out you don't need to come early
yeah so kind to you clowns oh they they
had a couple yeah yeah he popped
somebody in her mouth with a pepperoni
pizza does move
you know it's like the way king moves
people i move people you know what i
mean you know what i mean
through kind words very kind words and
you're doing some other kings there's a
different king that you talk about i
mean
i move people with my hand
continue
i might use sign language here and there
when i talk very emotionally but
is your hand in this
position continue
yeah you know you look at joe pishi you
know like that so um so i got i got my x
i'm happy with it i love it it loads
fast everything loads super fast even
stuff off the usb drives are loading
fast um a dude at ea jim heisel hooked
me up with this new thing that he's
developing it's called the ssd
switchblade and it's basically an nvme
on top of like a usb
stick and you plug it in
and i
downloaded destiny against all my
goodwill oh good man good man
destiny too and it felt like i was
loading it off the internal man it was
so quick crazy right
yeah and that's the that's the power of
the x-man because you know the 1x
wouldn't have done that quick even for
an nvme on the side but yeah so
everything dude everything on the series
x this is the console that you need you
need this in your house if you if you're
a hardcore gamer and you love video
games and you want to play you know
everything from back compat to game pass
to whatever comes out in the future this
series acts as where it's at you can't
even beat
anything in the market for the price
that they stack in the power of that
thing you know not even a pc part you're
spending like 900 bucks on a damn
graphics card i'm just spending 500
bucks on a console even spawn waves said
he has no idea how they got that out for
500 yeah just the idea components and
stuff but let me ask you this uh because
again i wanted i'm glad clowns is on
because you're the only person i know
that has a ps5 digital so i want to know
did you get a chance to really get you
know touch that a lot and what's your
experiences with that
well i have a lot of bad experiences
with the ps5 already what's going on um
see the problem is i've seen all these
bad experiences on twitter from king and
other people rebuilding databases
journalists like some of the like 10
journalistic units died because a
rebuilding database is corrupted so it's
still in the box and i have it got you
guys so you know
3 000 send it my way you get that
you're all good
i'm not going to take a risk on it right
now until i know that it's actually
going to work when i get it out of the
box because there's just too many issues
and i'm not trying to be
but
you know what i mean it's there's just
issues with it so
i just wanna
you know what's funny uh when kid smooth
was playing 2k on xbox and it crashed
like that yeah he was like he was like
man all this stuff happened on
playstation i'm scared he did he refused
to boot the game back up he's like i
ain't taking that risk yeah i mean look
i get it i mean i give you credit clowns
i mean as far as showing uh discipline
to not play because i don't know if i
could do that but if you're trying to
sell it yeah but you know it is what it
is but overall both experiences i mean
well your series x experience has been
solid
yeah and you know to get the ps5 i had
no issues at all
sony emailed me that pre-order email
said you know you game a lot in
playstation so you deserve this
pre-order basically and i don't even
know how they got that because i'm in
the top one percent on playing on xbox
so where all my time is is on xbox but
maybe maybe somebody at sony was like oh
we'll just send them an email because we
want them on playstation more still not
gonna happen guys i'm sorry xbox plays
to be
you give me you give me a dollar ps now
maybe
maybe i might spend like
two percent more of my time on there but
man you can't beat that xbox and that
game pass and the quality you know king
is out there cracking kneecaps and all
and people sending knees and he's
absolutely right man
you cannot beat the power of xbox about
the game sir
we'll get into that
yeah
anyway moving on let's get i gotta get
to see what you did uh we'll get you in
that kick
what's the last one we ready because
we're you're right
i got it so i got a it's uh anchor happy
boring day thank you king chew out brat
for comp consumer confusion oh my god
you're ridiculous shout out thanks for
being messy um what else we got um
let me see uh squirrely squirrely damn
uh canadian two dollar subject no pause
with all this pepperoni in the mouth dog
and i was waiting for somebody to yell
out pause because i'm like yo you popped
them in the mouth for the pepperoni
you just kept going with it
jason say something brother fallout
thank you cedric h wow thank you brother
29 super chat happy birthday cog and
king glad you're getting better
definitely good to be little by little
and then jansen actually says something
with the three hours of chat why am i
not a mod cog the disrespect yeah cause
you too loose with the mouth and we
gotta put you on time
[Laughter]
he asked that before yeah yeah with two
you gotta get in the behavior box first
and then we'll we'll consider man we we
gotta go at least two months before i
happen to be okay without you getting
into any drama with people on twitter
then you can think about getting them
but you don't have to make another
account then we'll talk thank you you
need piece from you sir jw final super
chat uh ps5 assembly required packaging
may be used as toilet oh my god gamestop
better be ready for ps5 boxless
trade-ins okay
did you win a playstation sir didn't he
win a place in the joint but anyway we
will we will continue attic man
experiences bro
uh about all these times just seriously
and uh first off let's talk about what i
had to do to secure this thing
i i had to so you know i planned on
going out there waiting till like three
in the morning to till 10 or even 5.
so i'm sitting there i'm talking to
uh to cognito and i'm like well let me
call gamestop real quick and see because
they won't tell you how many they have
you have to go up there after hours and
look at the piece of paper on the on the
front of it so i'll call him i'm like
man just tell me he's like i can't tell
you man i'm like okay
okay tell me this
should i come now
he was like well let me see how many
people's out there i'm already my heart
i'm like it's over like
i have to go see now because there's
already four three four people lined up
and it's eight o'clock the night before
he comes out he's like better leave
right now and i'm like
less
yeah i got up there about 7 30 and then
uh he he ended up putting the piece of
paper there was five yeah and ironically
i brought my brother he was the fifth so
we sat out there from
7 00 p.m to 10 a.m and text me the whole
time
so you know it wasn't a bad because we
actually
the other three people that was there
they were actually entertaining that's
what's up so it was actually a decent
time but man
it felt like it was never ending it
really did and i got that
i got that console home
and yeah
i
popped in state of decay first wow
it was the first game i tried and yeah
question what was it like
when it was like five o'clock in the
morning or four o'clock in the morning
what exactly were you doing were you
like like sleeping standing like i don't
i couldn't sleep i can't sleep like in
unknown places like it just like i can't
shut down in those type of
conditions i just i was up the whole
time wow i would sit there i i sat in my
car for a minute because we got to the
point where anyone that showed up is
like yo there's only five you leave her
there's problems
wait did y'all stop the line
well i mean
there's no more there's no reason for
them to stay there
i've never been more grateful for
someone opening up gamestop in my life
they go through there and i'm thinking
yo they came early they have to let us
grab and leave man that kid closed the
door right after she was in there i was
i was man
it's 30 minutes just let us pop and
leave
so we finally get in there and uh you
know i try stay the decay too and you
know right there i can already tell a
difference huge difference it's like a
completely different game
then i think i i even tried forza
horizon and i don't care too i don't
care about that game i didn't even
really tell the difference to be honest
with you on the forza horizon one right
i then i tried kingdom hearts three and
that was that was a difference like
i enjoy what i've played on it now
because uh
microsoft and bungie couldn't get that
patch out day one right i haven't been
playing it for the past couple days
because i've been playing pc trying to
get my my grind up on that light level
feel you but uh you know after this
this week of grinding for this raid ends
then i'm gonna go back and i'm gonna
play assassin's creed i'm gonna play all
these other games just chilling on my
hard drive and what's funny is like i'm
here my pc is here my xbox is right here
look at it like right now i have final
fantasy 13 downloaded because apparently
it's 60 frames too and i was like
i i can't remember like the last time
that i had access to so much on a day
one like because
you know i i got it i got to give it up
the macho in the chat he said yes
kingdom hearts
if microsoft wouldn't have pushed for
the way they're doing backwards
compatibility i honestly don't think
mike sony would have followed like i
think if microsoft would have went the
traditional way of you know we're just
gonna have day one games we would
literally have maybe 10 15 games on both
platforms right now
so you know i i enjoy what i'm playing
of it
obviously that they're uh we ain't
talking about games right now yeah
that's it but just your impressions we
got you we got you shout out to
rossignon with the 1500
and when it comes to the actual quality
of of the it it definitely doesn't feel
cheap like nothing about the console
feels cheap
how many fingerprints you got on it
i i haven't i mean i turn it on with the
controller so probably none besides the
one when i post i'd be hugging my xbox
too much yes yes we saw we saw your
picture sir we saw your picture sir you
had like two kids with you they had the
exhaust on one side
is it your picture right now you kissing
the xbox series
it's like you won a championship
you know a very nice uh thing i enjoy
what i've played of it i enjoy what uh
especially the controller you know i
think the controller is one of the best
things about it like yeah like it's like
it's like um you know king or elsewhere
he said like this may look like what
this controller is
but they're not the same controller like
they just they just look alike right
you know how about that latency the
response of this right
you can definitely tell that the part
that sucks is it's um
it's a type c charger right so i can't
hook it up to my pc i have to go out and
buy it like the same thing yeah same
thing with me my le2
because i want to play it on my pc
because uh my brother took his control
because he got the nice one the last one
they just made besides this one that's
the nicest controller and i was sitting
there and i kept taking it from him
every time he goes to work i go in there
and jack it
then he gave me the story he came here
yesterday he was like my controller and
i and i was like okay
i got that xbox series x controller
man this is type c i can't even use it
right now can't even use it wait uh
cognito you got a ps5 as well right yes
why don't you just use the cord that
came with the ps5 and plug it in there
you're right i can use that i just don't
want to
[Laughter]
say you're absolutely right you know
i've always got this thing where it's
like
you know how like when you get something
that's made for something in my mind i'm
like i feel like there's some special
functionality it's probably done you
know what i'm saying you know
i know it's just my mind i like to keep
things associated with what they came
with i definitely want to call it ocd
sir yeah yeah that should be yeah i
definitely want to give a shout out
my bad that's good um playing charge kit
comes out on the 18th so it'll get the
proper usbc accord and then the battery
pack to go in just nice for that
controller nice i definitely want to
give a shout out to uh because i want to
give a shout out to uh jansen in the
chat
he got two he was originally going to
sell me the second one dude didn't
charge any up costs like anything like
that he could have easily got like 800
dollars for him i don't know if i'd have
done it but he could easily have asked
for it and i ended up you know waiting
for 18 hours does that you guys know me
i wouldn't wait i wouldn't want another
week
that's like getting here till wednesday
you think i was waiting till wednesday
no you're good
so i ended up getting one for me and my
brother because of jansen no doubt no
doubt lord king
seeing the tweets see what's going on
you were able to secure how many
consoles and what's going on man well
you know
um the one percent shout out to ainsley
um
we go inside the store kind of different
it's a different thing for y'all yeah we
don't go in the store the same way as
other people so you know inside the
store name like yeah um he has uh four
uh series x's and he has uh one series s
so i'm like yeah cool what's up
yeah
so um as i'm walking inside i have my
own
i do that's that's the thing
yeah yeah credit card different
oh my god
oh my god yeah yeah
so i'm walking in right and um i got on
my iop joint right you know so
they're like oh it's him right here
at the same time trying not to die
because i'm sick as hell so i'm trying
to stay away from people so i got my
covert you know uh shield on i was like
yo yeah i'm here for my you know you
know
so um he's like yeah he got four on it
um
so so they bringing my joints out the
back um and they don't have no bags all
right so we come with our own bags
and um so i i have my consoles there
right they told me you know don't don't
factory reset don't do anything just you
know just bring them
all right so i brought my exes
and i gave them to them and they was
like well okay so you know x amount of
dollars come off
uh what are you looking to do yeah are
you looking to put that towards the
total i said nah nah nah give me those
uh those terabyte drives how many you
got it was like well we only got four
so i said well give me four then i said
you because i wanted you know to have it
for the ass but
now i'm just like okay sorry cool got it
oh those still little terrible things
these strong little joints and little
joints are strong they about their
business 200 i was strong
[Laughter]
it's the price to pay you know uh you
want you want to play all right
now so we get it and um going to the car
you know throwing them inside the car
little tight packages i'm like yo these
jewels
they like legos i'm like i'm like in the
car putting them in like touches
and then
so i'm driving to the house right and
you know
i'm
packing up a lung so uh i put one to the
side so the first thing i'm doing
putting the one in the main you know the
living room like yeah baby
i open up the box and i was just like it
was a come to jesus moment
was the light was the moonlight shining
on your back yo it was just like it was
just like over the shoulder rod just
looked down and i was like yo
hyperion and horus and
i was like yo this is this is bananas
and the first thing that popped in my
head was the greatest bid in the
business jason ronald's and i
was wow
thank you for the world wishes brother
it was sad in my heart that i had to
miss i did really did not want to miss
last week
um
it was a great day and i'm like yo
jason ronaldo's a wizard
yeah
his team is just the team mm-hmm
and all i could just do is drop the one
knee and see what's good
you did that
i said this is all possible
i said this this does not happen
this is crazy like you open the box and
it and they yo the way they set it out
they set it out like i can't like yo
like i'm i'm sorry dudes if if y'all
never went to a premium place and
purchase anything premium
if y'all never did it when you purchased
that plate that that that playstation 40
when you purchase this series x
this is a premium jump off
even the wrapping around because it took
different people to do different things
to get something yo they wrapped it up
and they threw a sleeve over it
the sleeves that power your dreams but
in between those dreams is in between
two pillowy cushions
you're really impressed with this
package
you know why i'm impressed with the
packaging because that's for the
packaging though before i get to that
before i get competition's
let's just continue let's go on this
premium ride
are you got to leave a part with the
your knees down yeah and the shot i'm
going to tim tebow my phone down i'm
down on them let's go let's get this
i'm like oh my god this is it right now
this is it we are here this is we are
here during the pandemic and they even
launched it good guard is about to go
down all right boom
they say yo i'm looking at this little
thing that they put in the box i'm like
what the hell is this
i'm gonna get your phone app out
i'm like okay so i put a message in my
box
got my phone app out and i'm like oh
okay
i was like yeah your joint is good i was
like what yeah
your joint good yeah the setup is clean
i said oh dear god
so yo so i had all my um i had like 19
terabytes of
of my external um hard drives hooked up
to it and then i put the the ssd inside
the back
so my joint is like it's to the gills of
already right
so i'm like
well what game should i should i try
what should i do
so i was like okay well i'm downloading
everything i want down below next i
definitely want to see gears i
definitely want to see pub g but the
first thing that popped up in my head
was tetris oh
alex favorite
i saw the tetris i said you know let me
download that tetris it downloaded so
fast
it was like boom you ready i was like
yeah
okay
i'm ready i'm ready for the test dress
let's let's just get it
yo
crazy the speed of this console the
quality of life of this console
i keep hearing people saying quality i
got a game on my xbox right i primarily
gamed on my one x
and i can tell you there's a marketable
difference that makes this
an experience
that
exponentially
is making it satisfying for me to pick
up the controller
like
from the controller it's it's it's a
it's a change you feel the textures it's
better
um
to the interface that they were bringing
you along for months you didn't notice
but it was little subtle things that
they was bringing you along with and
getting it ready so this transition was
seamless all i can say is this is the
most seamless transition from one
console generation to the next that it
may seem like there's nothing happening
but everything is happening factual you
cannot go back to your xbox one x after
playing any of these series consoles
it is
you put it back on you you would think
that you you fell into a time warp or
something like why is it so slow what
the hell is going on here
no this this is absolutely disgusting i
cannot do this i cannot get jiggy with
this
get this out of here
and there's i can see why they
discontinued the xbox one x i can see
why
i would have discontinued it too
all right so
now that we already got the premium
[Music]
most incredible experience i've ever had
with a console
generation ever
it's a big distinction
come thursday i'm amp i can't sleep in
the morning yeah yeah i'm like oh is the
playstation turn your turn next up i
believe that's me
[Music]
i took my theraflu boy the boy got the
mucinex in his body let's go through on
the next match where's the other mask
hold on hold on
hold on hold on so i i take on the next
mass and i'm like
i'm like yeah yeah yeah
you know what it is you know who it is
he's back
iop he here right so
they're like yeah yeah he got four of
those
different habits for you they had police
out there
the police like when i pulled up the
police was in the handicapped zone like
what up we out here with these guns wow
guns out guns ouch
guns out it was nobody outside though
but guns dissolved though
it was dead
all right and apparently i heard the
police was there for the ex but you know
everybody came like i came a little bit
later
so um i get in there trying not to cough
grab my stuff
so
they had one police officer outside next
to my car
one at the door
jesus one walking me to
my car damn
had four
so they was like yo what games do you
want
what the hell are you talking about give
me that miles morales he's like oh do
you want the remix what the hell is
wrong with you man just give me the
mouse the cheap jump man
the hell out of here
you don't want no demon souls i said why
i want a playstation 3 game man if you
don't give me that miles morales
got the joint
big like yo i feel real big i feel real
big
i feel real big out here you ever went
shopping shopping like i felt real big
out here i was real big
and then i had armed security so
the joint it really i felt like a rap
star
like a real rap star it was delicious i
walk into the car and they and my door's
open the police got my dog in
and i'm putting it inside now it's
different kind of legos because it's
like
right so i'm putting them inside the car
so so the cop is like oh so you gonna
play all i said hell no these three are
sold
he's like how much you sold them for
uh
he looked back inside the store like we
got to cop these right so
give him a pound i'm out of there right
so i go to dhl and i ship off
everybody's console and i get to the
house so when i get to the house i'm
like wow
let's do this
let's do this so so first first thing i
tweet out is the christopher hart i'm on
your head boy i seen it um so you know
we got this we got the videos because i
told dudes i'm i'm on all you
playstation dudes hey you said that you
was getting one i want to see your
videos i didn't see half of you i'm only
respecting christopher hart
i'm only respecting christopher hart all
you frauds all you kappas all you dudes
talking all that i'm a playstation dude
only real dude in these streets is
christopher hart face out had his boxes
and
and and showed his i respect you
christopher hall all day
anybody else they frauds i don't respect
you they had any system up
frauds they don't even got it i don't
believe them it's just borrowing
somebody else's boxes i don't believe
them
anyway
you said
i opened the box right
into my shocking horror
yes i said what the hell is this
what the hell is this man
you would not please just because
gets me
this is not what 500 gets me if you got
a box of yeezys you get some yeezys you
pay 500 600 for your sneakers and they
join just throw your joint in the box
yo
yo take these bootlegs back it felt like
somebody bootlegged me
i felt like somebody
[Music]
i pulled it out and i took it from this
little clap corn crap things and pushy
things on the side i'm like whose idea
was this
who did this to this
all right so i put it to the side and
i'm holding the joint
i'm like you're a monstrosity for no
reason
and then the plastic is cheap i'm like
oh
buddy
okay i got the little stand in the back
the stand don't even click on or nothing
dude so just yo so this is so hard this
is how trash the stan is so when i put
the stand in the back and i put it down
on the shelf i said okay let me
reposition it this it fell off the stand
i was like oh bro
so i had to go back in there and flick
it back in inside and put the little
standard use the screws
no the screw don't go that way
that the screw is only when you're
standing the dude up
my joint is laying down ain't no
stand-up position my dog ain't not
listening to that so
put him laying down right there right
i'm like yeah
okay okay let's get to this miles
now you already know
i'm a super miles head right i turned it
on i said let me put in my account my
joint
i cannot log into my playstation account
to this day
to this day nah dudes was telling me
they had issues anyway first day so i
said okay you know what i'm just gonna
play my game and then i'm gonna do it
when all the fever died down because i
believe everybody's trying to log in and
stuff like that i sent my email they
didn't send the re re-uh fix nothing so
i'm like okay whatever it's cool i'ma
get to that part i don't care as long as
i'm able to play miles i don't care
right
and i i felt that the dual sense
controller
is the best playstation controller ever
made fire and i said saying much because
i always thought playstation had a
crappy controller
all right but
like amy says you know these these
triggers is trash
but um and and you know this is it's
cheap you know i don't what i don't like
here they should have shaved this down
right here because it's like it's like
somebody just it can cut you
really
you rub your finger on it
all right then so it could cut you so
what you need to do they needed to shave
this down or whatever you know um but it
is the best playstation controller
and you know like i said it's not saying
much because i don't like the game over
there anyway but
um for the once or twice a year that i
do go over there and play on it
it's definitely the best playstation
controller the box is too big then i
have to do a revision
one thing that people aren't talking
about when you boot it up and turn it on
i want you to do it with no surround
sound on no headset on your head if you
have the disc version and you have a
disc inside
it's going to sound like a car is
starting
it is loud
it is loud and nobody is talking about
this
it starts off my dog was across the room
and said what the hell is that
and ran over to the playstation and
looked back at me like yo this new big
thing that you just put in
this thing fit in the blow by guys
and i'm like i'm looking at him like
you'll calm down and then after a couple
of seconds it'll calm down and then
it'll get quiet it doesn't make any more
noise after that but
initially
terrible
so my experience with the playstation um
i can talk to you about it later when we
start talking about the games but uh
if we're going off a presentation and
everything i'm gonna give it a five yeah
um the xbox i'm gonna give it a 10.
uh if you're going to give it a size uh
comparison i'm going to give it a five
right the overall to me
uh the controller bumps it up uh two
more notches so it is a seven to me and
you know the xbox is detained completely
no doubt no doubt let me see the super
chat somebody's been following super
chat when i opened up that series x
packaging i felt that scene from pulp
fiction when they opened the briefcase
i do remember that salute and let me get
down five one two one superchat pub g60
frames it's a game changer one twenty
sixty yes very good yeah pixel bit g
damn they skipped me they skipped me all
the way just about to read pixel bit
okay there we go pixel bear final switch
i tried to put the one x on for my
four-year-old and he said no daddy i
don't want my game to be slow put on the
big xbox
welcome to the next gen absolutely
regulated chat va my son opened my xbox
series x the startup was a super
exciting emoji you already know so i'm
look i'm very quick everybody said
everything i needed to say already i
mean like i said which is very happy to
secure on the series x for the microsoft
store was very was checking fedex
notifications very feverishly just
making sure but you're coming i was
giving every fedex driver decide i did
not stop that my house so oh salute the
fedex for you know keeping it steady
tall um yeah look you know um as far as
the um the playstation i was able to get
that at gamestop look same thing you
guys said xbox series x premium premium
packaging very cool experience i love
the boot up i love setting it up the app
was a great addition i didn't i was
actually hesitant to use it at first
just because i you know i'm like i'm
setting up my console with a phone app
this is very interesting very different
but um yeah it was so seamless and just
having me do things while it's going on
in the background very painless process
system's very slick very smooth the
monolithic design got to love it um
playstation 5 man
it was funny got it from gamestop you
know and uh it's funny he's getting
everything ready for me and i'm getting
ready to go out
and i'm like yeah so the bag
so he's like nah man
no bag big enough for this
so you're going to have to go out there
and brave yourself with a big logo on
your chest playstation 5 rob me now
so i'm like this is not it y'all like
cool you didn't have security like king
no i don't i don't i'm not on that
lifetime right
but for me i was just like damn like i
feel sorry i see why king is talking
about they had the 5-0 out there for
they launched like because there's no
bag big enough to fit so um you know
anyway lives in a better neighborhood
so anyway you know i get it back like i
said you know set it up one thing yes it
is humongous playstation 5 is no there's
no dancing around it it is a big system
i'm like damn it's really it's really
that big
so but to my surprise very light that
series x surprised me with the weights
yeah
so then this surprised me with the
height so the only thing i would say is
that um you know ainsley's going to kill
me but i was forced into the horizontal
life man nope
it was nothing i could do i want to be
the tower of power with both but i just
i i
my unit was like bruh you're gonna have
to put them down like loaf of bread and
that's it and shout out to alcoholism
because he was like yo why cog systems
look like two beached whales
[Laughter]
yo he killed me or they killed me my
pictures on twitter they killed me i
gotta send some people your way man i'll
take care of you please please i'd like
you to build another section of the room
in my house but um yeah
he said now you have better oh you
horizontal gang okay
no no don't listen
it do look like a loaf of bread doing
this side but it looks horrible yeah
they look like they don't look
aesthetically pleasing buff over them on
the side but anyway look we got it to
work we tested out all i would say quick
super fast systems um series x very very
zippy ui is pretty much you know the
same but just refined controller the
same but refined i will say the latency
was a big game changer for me on that as
far as the playstation 5 man i was
impressed with that controller i really
was it had a little bit more weight i
understand when you're coming from
ainslie though as far as the the
triggers and stuff like that you know
obviously i'm always going to be a fan
of the what you call it when the analogs
are separate in this place but i forget
where you know this thing the xbox one
yes so i'm always going to be a fan of
offset but i do feel this is their best
controller and we'll get into the games
but you know
astrobot was just next level to me yeah
that was just okay this is now granted
we got to see if other games they're
going to utilize it but at the end of
the day man super impressed with that
and i will say to the last point ui like
brad said um
at first i was like okay i don't mind it
but as i played more with the ui
i started to get a little bit annoyed
because i'm like damn like it's an extra
button pressed to do things and where's
this at and how come i just can't go to
my friends and obviously the dynamic
themes is a big deal for me because to
me that's the identity of playstation
you know i always boot my favorite deal
okay don't they charge you for those
dynamic themes on ps4 i would say to pay
bro i have my goal
no no i like my
viewpoint it's like
you pay all this money for like to
pre-order it to get dynamic themes and
it's just like the ps5 they're like we
don't care if you paid that money we're
starting he's saying that it didn't
carry right you know yeah
can't even use it so that hurt because
to me that was their ace in the hole
always over xbox i always felt that
playstation
had personality with the ui you know
it's crazy yeah
this microsoft has a form of dynamic
things
right now
we'll get into more deep with the
quickest zooming on that when we get
into but yeah like overall like i said
both
very happy you know next gen is here and
then we'll get into the joint but look
we got to move on cause we got a lot of
showing and we kind of get we're getting
behind but um you want to get uh super
chester
yeah i have no clue which ones you done
i was in the other room okay all right
i'll get uh i believe sorry if i missed
anybody but michael um aka bedstock
finest um my son george dropped what he
saw forza horizon 4 when he saw me
playing forza horizon on my series x 100
mind blown you already know jonathan v
find out super chat i thought i would
have to fight my fedex driver
they delivered my blue controller an
expansion card first then three hours
later delivering fostering factual
stories factual stories i know i know i
know the vibes i know the vibes shout
out to shane tomlin if i found um happy
the happy names day cogs look glad king
lannister is better
but hope his escalade blows up as i
didn't get my series x laugh out loud
i'm not getting the escalade sorry so i
needed 10 playstations in order to
achieve set escalade all i did was pay
bills oh my god so says the book of wood
x all right so cool so let's move on man
so look i want to get um i don't know if
kid is still with us
gary okay i get you man look let's get
kid brad because i know you guys got um
playstation and um obviously um aims and
myself so um yeah man look ps5
impressions you know now that you got a
chance to deep dive you know i'm saying
what as far as the the games and what's
standing out to you what do you feel it
um
as far as your playstation um right now
yeah it's um
spiderman obviously expected that to be
great but astrobot you know like i said
it's a cool tech demo uh for the
controller the game looks good it's cute
um it serves that you know platforming
uh
necessity for a new console launches
since there's no knack this year
but um
i i just i've been enjoying it the crazy
thing is right and i'm gonna tell you
guys right now nuke having multiple
consoles at some point it is overrated
because i to uh this week i realized
i can only play one game
so i'm playing i i took some time for so
day one i took some time on spider-man
stream spider-man and then i tried uh
days gone and then i i i took the rest
of the night off stream playing astro
bot and then
i took friday completely off playing
dude this is the games i played
friday right what's up
i got blessed with a full review package
of call of duty black ops it was uh cold
war was not expecting that right
so i played that
and of course i'm trying to keep myself
together assassin's creed valhalla
because i don't i don't i don't know how
to put that game down
dude that game is just oh my god i'm
jealous
you know what's crazy though i keep
forgetting how
like that quick resume is there
something like oh let me turn around
yeah let me turn my console on right
i'll go back and then that's creepy the
last game i played so from the time that
i'm booting up the xbox right to getting
on the last point where i was at in
assassin's creed and it's usually on
like top of a rooftop it's literally
like within like three seconds and i'm
like what the crap y'all i'm like i'm
used to like turn on the game waiting
for the thing to load up i'm like
checking my phone bro that cold boot is
lit continue yeah
yeah so it's just been like i've been
playing it yo sleeper this is a sleeper
bro and if people slept on it because
you know the early previews and stuff
dirt five
is that game really
dirt bot bro
i was like you know what let me put this
in man let me let me just give it a shot
right yeah let's go i'm playing in i
went straight to like uh the image
quality mode man
you bro i
i felt foolish i literally thought that
game was doing full-on ray tracing
that's yo that's how good
their um what their sso is
like i'm like yo
crazy i'm like i'm like wait a minute
this can't be the same game people were
trashing a few months back it can't be
like so i'm playing that game i'm joy it
feels good because it was made by the
same devs that did the game on the rush
so it's the i've tried games in the past
like dirt 4 and dirt rally i didn't like
them but this dirt
i'm loving it right i am loving it if i
suggest if anybody got it give it a try
check image quality roll you they got
the reflections are on point the hdr is
on point and i tried the game in 120 uh
frames the mode and um it's working man
they did a good job with that game um
but yeah um in between in regards like
the and then there's one game
that i i i
actually that was probably one of the
first games i played for the series x it
was bright memory 1.0 oh yeah yeah
yeah we gonna talk about i forgot kid i
was waiting to get you on the
playstation but i know you're jumping on
the same side
yeah my bad yeah don't think about
playstations that i didn't play like i
skipped the whole entire day i skipped
friday and i played uh a little bit
yesterday because i played i remember i
played like three hours of spider-man
yesterday in another hour of astrobot um
yesterday um but the thing is is that
i i don't know what more can be said but
i don't have demon souls yet okay
um did you get miles did you move
yeah i'm playing now the thing is here's
the cheat right spider-man had not been
for
assassin's creed odyssey right
spider-man the original one in 2018
would have been my game of the year
right okay so i i'm knowing like it's
like all right we got miles morales my
son's a big mas morales fan it's hard to
play that because he keeps trying to
take the controller
um
so he um the game
i respect the game but it's it's also on
like you know on um
playstation 4 but the the ps5 version in
terms of like i said i tried the ray
tracing mode like there were specific
scenes where i was like you know what
let me go to the fidelity mode because
you know how they walking through like
the the little parade and everything i
got the fidelity mode on there
yeah
yeah yeah so um
it looks great man they did a wonderful
job they they did whatever they can to
take advantage of the controller the the
low times is like
one thing i do give a shout out to
playstation for is like because a lot of
people will you know point out point to
xbox quick resume playstation doesn't
have it right but if you're playing
playstation 5 games
you'll realize they don't need it how
quick the games rolled in right like i
did a test i went from like i think i
went from astrobot to the back to
spiderman i was like it did it so quick
i was like alright it operates like
quick resume but it's not quick resume
you know what i mean because once you
after you boot through a game once you
don't see all the logos anymore right
right yeah so it's like okay so it they
have a solution it's it's still fast but
um
yeah i haven't i haven't had um any
issues with my playstation fingers
crossed
i also haven't been trying to stress my
playstation looking at twitter like the
issues people haven't so i know a lot of
the games that people are having issues
with are like godfall which was one of
the games i really wanted um
2k call of duty um
and i've seen issues with spider-man
where you get to play as a light post
and a brick of wood or something like
that but
being glitchy or not so i haven't had
any of those issues and i'm hoping like
you know i had a blessed playstation
where it's not going to experience those
but not so far man the games have been
cleaned they look great um no doubt
yeah and
i don't know man fair enough kid fed up
kid yo brat lord brad what's going on
man playstation five badges now that you
deep dive for a couple days you know
what's getting out to you man
yeah absolutely real quick i i got a
heart stop at one o'clock so i'm gonna
yeah i'm gonna make this uh as quick as
possible but um look uh miles morales uh
it's it's really stood out to me so far
demon souls i fired up haven't really
got into it but looks great so far um
but miles morales i mean i i haven't
played it on performance mode i've been
playing it with uh you know for like
like ray tracing everything because i
wanted to see that
um and the game looks great on the
playstation 5. it really does the city
just seems more alive
um the the the colors pop the production
values in this game hats off to
insomniac by the way
what what a great game this is um
the the music the voice acting
everything about this game is just top
tier
and i'll say this about the playstation
5 launch it this is probably their best
launch
that i can remember on a playstation
console sony has been uh look if if i
think back to the place this is the best
playstation launch in the playstation
console
yes if you've never had a playstation 2
if you look at if you look at places
look if you look at playstation 1
playstation 2 playstation 3 playstation
4. i think that the one thing that sony
has
with this launch is they have a little
bit of everything for everyone
you know they have stuff for the kids
they have a platformer they have a game
like miles morales that will appeal to
casuals they have a game for the
hardcore gamer and demon souls
you know
yeah it's subjective you know
yeah so i i just think i think they
knocked out the park with with the
offerings of games that they have they
some of the games actually surprised me
uh with uh you know reading some of the
reviews for like buck smacks like i'm
not gonna play butt snacks but actually
rated good too yeah yeah yeah bug snacks
was good it's not what people think it
is
yeah
pathless bug snacks i'm trying to get
slow-mo backslap to play bug snacks hey
by the way everyone listening right now
go to the snowmobile backslaps channel
on youtube yes
and subscribe get him to a thousand
subscribers he will play
snacks and stream it he has been
fighting us tooth and nail please
subscribe to my man uh
slow mo backslap on youtube if you can
get him to a thousand subs yeah we want
him playing bucks next yeah he's gonna
stream it yeah but
but uh yeah i gotta say man i have um
i've been pleasantly impressed with uh
the games and and if you think about um
i go back to miles morales i mean my
kids are
dying to play i'm not letting them play
it though i'm like
you guys can wait
go you guys can wait you know
daddy get through yeah the the games are
just great uh you know and the haptic
feedback controller too go back to that
yeah uh it's nice if some third party
games are taking advantage of it uh call
of duty
uh for what i hear does a really good
job
at uh utilizing the haptic feedbacks
uh on the dual sense like forte was
talking about it on brad he said like
the different weapons you could feel
like different tension like with the
shotgun there's a different engine to it
and i was like wow so i'm going to pick
that up too
but uh yeah i look solid launch i think
for the playstation 5 with games again i
i think the best uh launch lineup
they've had i think definitely better
than playstation 4. um
no i agree with you there i definitely
agree because four was just like resogun
yeah um
knack and i believe it was a killzone
shadow for i i definitely look it's a
strong launch i you made a good point as
far as the um variety of titles at
launch and obviously some exclusives man
but
i was gonna say because i could check
just
drugs oh my god clearly you didn't like
it
no but uh you know i'm gonna say and
then demon souls to me i think is
probably
the best looking game right now
exclusive game right next gen game out
there right now for what i've seen so
far
um and that's kind of i think i've been
that's that's kind of the consensus that
i've seen from people who are playing it
it is
yeah i think i think you may have said
that on your show yesterday yeah it is
yeah
trust me i've played them all it is
yeah
i just i think gear smashes it in the
mouth
that ain't a new experience either
love everyone here on the panel you guys
are all fantastic and do great work in
the community and how can i find people
find you sir
absolutely you can find me uh on youtube
at basement radio arcade podcast live
every wednesday night 9 p.m eastern
standard time and uh on twitter at rap
podcast so come check us out
we have a good time and uh gentlemen
it's been a pleasure absolutely thank
you so much
uh enjoy your sunday thanks for pulling
up man i really appreciate it later
absolutely absolutely guys take care
have a good one man yep no doubt no
doubt ainsley
lord ainslie
station five man what's standing out
from you know the game standpoint and
now you've had time with it
yeah so i'm i'm kind of weird i know we
talked about this before i'm not a a big
superhero game guy so i'm one of the
very few who bought ps5 but i don't have
miles and i won't be playing it um i i
have spider-man and i i played it a
little bit i just it's just not my type
of game which is
it is what it is right um
but um
for me it was all about deepen souls i'm
a big souls guy uh all the souls games
bloodborne etc
and uh demon souls is one of those games
that because it came out so long ago and
was played by so few right um you know
and blue point are masters at what they
do right so
um this is like playing it's
king's right it is a ps3 game this is an
old game just like resident evil 2 was a
ps1 game right um but because i never
finished it because it's been over a
decade and my memory don't go back that
far
um this is like a new experience right
so
um
that's the one that got me really hyped
uh to play at launch and it's it's
incredible i would say that between it
and valhalla those are the two games
that are bar none taken up
no
they're above everything else in my
opinion right now for launch
um but yeah it's stunning man it's
absolutely stunning like pictures don't
do it justice because you take a picture
then it gets compressed on twitter and
everything i'm telling you you see it in
person it is
it's almost mind-blowing
not to cut you that's actually a good
point you made and i'm a little
frustrated with xj in that regard
because i feel
the quality of what we are seeing on
screen unfortunately now screenshots are
not doing it justice but continue no no
it's a problem even for the devs right
because they're trying to show off their
games and you just can't show the
experience like you have especially if
you're on an oled and hdr and you know
what i mean if you've got the right
setup
it's nuts so i was streaming it the
other night people were you guys are yes
yeah we can hear you could tell you
um i was streaming it the other night
and people were saying man that looks
incredible and i'm like then remember
this stream is only 1080p right like if
you could see it in person it's it's
mind-blowing um you have the 3d headset
no no i use a i got a home theater man i
don't use headsets
okay no no the only reason why i'm
asking because a lot of people that's
been playing demon souls have been
explained uh to me that they can feel
like that arrows whiz past their head
though yeah i'm going like that you can
yeah well i mean you know i have the
surround you can it's it's nuts and the
the uh dual sense on demon souls it's so
like um
it's like uh you swing your sword you
hit something and you feel it right but
if you hit a body and connect versus
like if you someone blocks it with a
shield it feels different right also
it's it's really immersive in that
regard it's it's it's just really really
good and i'm actually kind of mad with
myself because i'm streaming it as a
series
um and so i can't really play it when
i'm not streaming because i'm trying to
make it a walk like a walk through you
know what i mean right
um but no that that game on ps5 has
jumped out for me yeah i think um
that game single-handedly is the only
reason i don't know between that and
ghost because i do want to play ghost
legends yeah yeah but like that game
like because i i'm definitely one of
those people that i can i can
say yes that's an old game
but i'm willing like that is one of the
games that jump started this dark souls
era yep and i am willing to bet you the
majority of the dark souls fans have
never played that game
100 yeah i've talked to a lot of them
and i'm one of them right like i have my
ps3 copy from when i bought it um but i
never finished it you know it's you go
back and play it now it's a joke right i
mean it's really really dated um so this
is just something special and i i keep
telling people people keep wanting to
play it but they're like i don't play
souls games and i'm like the only thing
i'll say is it is so smooth
that
souls games if you know them they've
always been a little janky right like
the engine is just dated um this is so
smooth it plays more like a modern
action game
than a souls game it's still really hard
don't don't let me scare you wrong you
you almost sold me because i'm not a guy
i was like damn
you can still dive real real fast you
know it takes one mistake but um it just
plays a lot better so anyway um that
one's jumped out to me um i
i like a mix again
let's go let's go let's go i was gonna
joke about bug snacks it's not even
worth the time
i did play for 15 minutes just to see
you know and i'm like this is you know i
could see
it's cutesy it is what it is you know we
don't need to really mess around with it
i also bought um
what a must am i playing astrobot is
incredible
it's incredible um it's a short game
it's a pack in it's it's obviously made
to demo the dual sense right you know
i want to because i haven't played it
but what i've seen on it
yeah i have to give it i already have to
give it the the title of like the best
game that comes with the console
yeah i was talking about that yesterday
because i was like you know if you count
super mario world or mario will forget
about it that's the legend right but
um i honestly agree with you i think
if once you play it much higher
once you go through the levels and
experience it it's it's an excellent
excellent game it's short you know you
can finish in three to four or five
hours um like i was talking to some
buddies playing it the other night but
it's it's really really good right um
and it's not just a demo in that sense
it's actually got levels and everything
else so anyway um other than that i'm um
i actually bought sackboy i love 3d
platformers
um i just going all the way back to
uh alex kidd shout out
and gotta call out mario and all those
games man i love platforming games so i
had to check out sackboy and it's
actually really good too um
it's uh it's much better than i thought
it was gonna be i bought it as kind of
like i'll play this on the side you know
what i mean yeah um it's a good game
it's got a hub base world's got a great
sense of humor the soundtrack is
actually surprisingly good um it doesn't
do a whole lot with the dual sense it's
got the normal rumble and stuff but um
sac boys it's really really good so
overall that's what i'm playing i know
everyone asks about miles i'm the one
person probably not playing miles
um but i've had a good time with it man
um i i have had a couple issues uh that
have scared me um sort of crashing
so demon souls crash mid playing
yesterday it just literally like boom
and it gave me the error screens
depending on what you're doing that
could be a problem
yeah oh adding i was running around
trying to bam
luckily i was i was just grinding for
stuff in between my stream so i was just
getting like materials and stuff but i
was just mid walking through a level and
it's just bam problem with the
application demon souls i couldn't i
couldn't imagine be like fighting the
last boston chakra or something like
that and then it does that in the middle
of it i probably would unplug the
playstation and throw that again so
let's let me stop you for a second so
basically
because i saw shout out to erica erica
for the wish you i saw her tweet in kind
of a similar situation but her seemed
like a a pause oh no that so that's
different okay so mine just straight
crashed
there's different
problems yeah yeah yeah
i know the clip you're talking about and
i've had i remember i responded to you i
said i've had that happen twice so like
it's it's almost unexplainable like
i was mid walking up steps i can picture
it and i was walking up to this guy and
i went to swing and my guy kind of went
like this and then the game just froze
and i was like what the hell's going on
and then about three seconds later he
swung and it just continued like normal
so it was almost like just a literal
system pause for a couple seconds so
you know i get into this stuff from a
tech perspective i don't know what the
hell that is i don't have an answer
um so it's it's kind of scary and then
yesterday morning when i first woke up
and went to play right
i got the disc version i'm an old school
guy
and i um
yeah i went to start i turned on my ps5
and when it turned on the dashboard was
pink and purple and pixelated oh
and i was like okay this doesn't look
good right and then
and then i went to uh i went to um reset
it because my demon soul's disc was in
the drive
and it did that chainsaw sound you'd
never want to hear
you know
yeah all right i was like i just kind of
stuck back and i was like because i had
four of these damn things and they're
all gone because i gave them to friends
and stuff
and i'm like oh don't do it to me man
don't do it to me luckily it's been fine
since but i've had a few scares with it
that have kind of caught me off guard
yeah i mean it is interesting because i
think you know obviously we've been
seeing a lot of it obviously king has
mentioned it too you know we're going to
see
you know a lot of reports of
people freezing
you know uh crashes you know some ui
stuff we don't know if it's tied exactly
to the rest mode but it is a concern
because
it doesn't seem to be an isolated issue
i don't want king i'm gonna get king
next you know we'll get into as far as
his experience but yeah this is
something that's going around so i'm
curious to hear what your experience was
i i've had a few weird things for sure
um but uh other than that it's been okay
i'm just you know new console launches
brand new tech i got my fingers crossed
nothing happens um the only other thing
i wanted to shout out real quick is um
so ps5 doesn't have quick resume um and
that's once you get used to having quick
resume it's like king was saying there's
no going back yeah um
the one thing it does have though is it
has activities they call it which is um
so say i'm playing demon souls and i
turn off the system i come back to it
when if you when you go to the ui and
you highlight demon souls if you go down
a step it's got these cards across yes
and what you can do is you can actually
jump into that game at different points
depending on where you played it oh wow
so like for instance demon souls has
five hub worlds and i was just kind of
exploring and running around them right
so i can launch the game where it will
take me into different points depending
on which one i pick gotcha so it's not
quick resume and you can't keep multiple
games running right but what it does do
is allow you the game you were playing
and allows you to get back into it at a
point uh like instantly it's super fast
not fair enough yeah enough which is
cool let me see what you just gotta
definitely miss some oh chaos solante
follow switch salute to the lords kings
folks still commenting on the miles
video i sent you can't bring myself to
continue miles afraid to break my ps5
and then you ain't even been talking in
the background all right one second wow
you missed um all right so i got him
there okay there we go so um
clutchman015 just popped in don't know
if anyone asked is there confirmation
that there will be more series x's on
black friday weekend have a good show
guys yeah yeah there will be yes
if you don't get that one you're
probably gonna have to wait until next
year shout out shout out to the basement
radio brad find out super chat salute
lost that you've had me on thank you for
rocking with us enrique salute scrub
nurse five dollar super chat shout out
to the lords of the chat hope everyone
is enjoying launch week and shout out to
the saints sorry cog your boys are going
down there you killing my daughters damn
salute
oh i dizzy does astrobot have a better
tech devil and wii sports did legit
question i don't remember we sports too
much because i don't believe i had so
king had to answer that we sports it was
good but what i'm seeing is like
wii sports was something mainly for
casual people that hardcore people kind
of enjoyed and you know but it wasn't
the
go-to like what i'm seeing on here they
they they're putting you know the
playstation history in it they're
putting the controller down esports is
the greatest packing game period
yeah
the wii sports
it is the fastest most popular selling
system period so regardless to what that
package is
playstation 4 is the most selling thing
this platform you don't see that's it i
don't know what that packaging was but
i don't know what that package was but
you could tell let me know what the
package was moving on briscoe
cop a series x and two ps5 digital soul
one shout out to king sony owes us one
foot on the hdmi cable all right
yeah it is too short
yeah he's right right he's right it is a
little short kick man let's get to it
bro um you know europe pressures down
with playstation five i just get um
clowns i know you didn't pick up one in
an attic but um
yeah what's your experience man as far
as like the games now you got time with
it
okay so
i threw on um the miles morales and
um
it felt like home like
it felt like because you know that's my
game of the year so i said y'all got me
man y'all got me i got me oh y'all got
me i don't care what come hella high
award i was getting that game
i was like i was gonna buy the whole
remastered joint and then um i saw the
face of peter park and i was like no
good
soul yeah that's a big controversy yes
it is disgusting it's disgusting what
they did to my peter parker
with the clowns what they did to my boy
[Laughter]
and it's off because
if you look at mary jane she's older
yeah but now parker looks younger
to fit in line with some stupid
narrative that they would they had a
whole
smart thing even when you control
spider-man
he controls mature right when you
control miles
he's immature he he controls like a kid
his animations is like a child right
right so um
i i don't
it was a disgusting move on their part
that's not to cut you to make them
younger yeah your defense because i'll
be i'll be the first like i've been in
need of you and kind of botsu on this
because i was the first look i'm fraud
and i ain't finished the first one right
so my whole thing was i saw the actor
change and i'm like casual cog was like
mcu
yeah yeah i'm like tom holland let's get
it well mcu accurate and
you and kai were like definitive no this
is a bad move i'm telling you cog the
the the facial expressions the the way
it's just yeah it's
it's just um
from the tone from the game not even
that is he's an older character right
and the spider-man he he you know if you
if you play the dlc's the dlc's is very
mature in nature and has to deal with
pregnancy and deadbeat dads and stuff in
situations of that nature
tom holland is a child right so what
it's just it doesn't fit right the last
one i'll give it right back to you the
last point i want to say is that in your
defense
shout out to neo game spark he has a
tweet up and he has like three of like
these very i guess emotional scenes but
and showing the the hurling
and the original and i ain't gonna lie
like the expressiveness of that original
actor that played was night and day and
what you call it was a little bit more
dead face the new guy but continue yeah
so had they never changed the face of uh
the original actor i would have picked
up the whole remix thing but i was like
nah i got the whole game and i'll just
play that um and brute force it if it
does some extra stuff i don't care and
but i'm playing the mouse so
story control feel
the subtleness on the controller
it's uh genius
they didn't ask me to blow into the
controller right um
so i cuz you know i think that's kind of
disgusting you didn't get to that part
yeah kid got it
if there's a part in that game i got to
blow on the controller yeah like the
king could literally have a stream with
astrology
so so on the blowing in the controller
right on astrobot here's something i
found which is kind of stupid so the
game tells you to blow on the controller
it shows you doing it right
i couldn't get it to work and i'm like i
was getting mad i was about to turn the
game off
i found out i was in a party chat with
my friends and what you what it actually
did is all it does is take sound from
the microphone you don't it doesn't
recognize anything so all i did was put
my mic in front of my face and go ah
it worked right away trust me
[Music]
it's whatever they're going to drop the
gimmick in a year anyway so it doesn't
matter jesus you know oh let's just
please stop acting like sony don't do
this like you know they come out with
something and
you know get you all lathered up and
then
leave you all loose
excellent so i i i already know what
they're going to do but
um
it did exactly what i asked it to do my
playstation besides crashing on me oh
lord um you know and i was playing you
know and i was ready right so i'm at the
top of a building and um there's a crime
that's happening at the bottom right
this is the most heart you know this is
it destroyed me it destroyed me because
i had the whole it was a whole group of
them it was at the bottom it was red
right so i'm flying all the way down and
i'm doing my venom strike and i'm coming
all the way down i hit the floor with
the venom strike and it was like boom
and my joints said
[Laughter]
my
yo i looked at my control i said
wow what wow the hell
just
happened wow
so i had to get up and i had the manual
because it didn't come back on
and i had to hold the power button for
30 seconds for the pop-up and it was
like yo we reconstructed me at your
joint and then i saw somebody on um
on like an influencer talked about it
only that's the only one you know all
these other fake fraud influences out
here they got they they playstations and
they're not talking the truth shaymin
and the devil
you know um
y'all are misleading the public just
because you got a free box y'all don't
want to tell the truth i don't i don't
care if you got a free box tell the
truth
you know um and what you're trying to do
is you're trying to hold it down so
people don't know what's going on
and people are looking over to you and
you're not telling them yo you're
joining like four or five freaking times
they ain't doing it because of that
they're doing it because they want to
stay in sony's good graces
aag who who said his is
that bricked i believe yeah well good
for him good for him to tell the truth
like they had to send him a replacement
unit yeah good everybody subscribe to
him and know that he's telling you the
truth jeremy's real yeah
you know these other dudes that got
these boxes that ain't telling you the
truth or what's going on so i got you
know i got a lot of vitriol online i
mean that tweet is probably at like 50
000 right now
and you know a lot of dudes just talking
about oh you just hate the playstation
well i don't care
i got it you don't got it so you just
hate me right and um if i'm telling you
that it bricked on me
and but it came back to life you know
that because some dudes was like really
concerned like yo my god did it come
back did you what was you able to do
what did you do so i talked to a couple
of dudes through it and then right after
that everybody start posting their
pictures right
and i'm like this is more widespread
than i thought right
right and then i'm just seeing people
playing
and it's
the thing with call of duty so i didn't
have any problems
with astrobot
astrobot
is
see because i play those games i spend
the money for mario's before for my for
my nintendo switch i love those games so
like i was telling cog playing the game
was so amazing i saw the water and these
things in the in the wood and so when i
was teasing chris and i'm like playing
in the water
is out of control but i do that in my
house so like my streams would be crazy
because i'm out of control like singing
in the trees
[Music]
you didn't have to tease that man if you
had your sister first like that i was
hilarious yeah what i was telling
incognito about the whole screenshot
thing i was like
just think about how many people posted
those screenshots saying their console
like randomly turned off in this small
community i was like that that's kind of
crazy i've never seen that like so many
people in this community having the same
issues yeah it's it's that's that's so
sad
um
but
i'm glad that it came back on right
then i heard because some people didn't
yeah some people didn't you know so i
said you know buy a warranty and this is
like somebody hit me
well this is what happens when you're
early opt in and i said that's what
happens when you broke you just look at
me but um
it's it's it's sad that you know
that
i think honestly
they knew that some of these crashes and
stuff would happen because they're
saying it's part of the memory kernel
and
is the ssd too fast for the memory to
catch up to what's going on
um some something is happening that is
not talking to the console properly that
it always has to reconstruct
the the memories yes
so it's it's it's kind of disconcerting
but it hasn't happened to me again okay
i'm still enjoying my spider-man i'm
almost finished with it but then you
know i'm gonna i'm gonna do i'm doing
like attic right now i'm just i'm not
going for book bags and none of that
stuff
just trying to play it for
nobody got time for that now i'm gonna
get my book bags later man i'm not gonna
do like you okay but
it is once you turn that game off you
ain't going back
[Music]
when's the last time you went back to
this other spot in my game don't cap
oh when the week before my house came
out i had my okay
you got this it's all
yours it's the greatest i'm well i see
i'm i'm a cabin
because it's the greatest
game for me yeah like it's
i i can't believe they did it like how
they did it and they did it so well in
the the latino community okay
and mixing all the spanish people
together it's kind of disrespectful you
know because you know you're not at me
hole if you're puerto rican and it's
it's kind of they're doing the kind of
spanish wrong you know my girl was like
what are they doing but
i said but they got the music money and
they got the you know everybody swinging
his balls
i like it i like the fact that they're
doing it and then
they're they're showing the ethnicity in
the game
you know they moved them to harlem i
really didn't like that that's kind of
right bro he was on the train he was
gonna go to one two fifth then he had
the tips it that's so new york bro off
the title screen alone is so new york
man i just sat there and smiled big man
i was and why for the fullest baby yeah
but he didn't live in harlem though
all right all right
what is what up so uh i love
i love spiderman yeah and i love that i
got this and i just hope they got more
dlc to go with this dlc
cold shot continued
oh
he always does this continue no that was
fun that was classic we got set up
because that was true that was funny i
need more dlc
overall you're good with that though
you're all good yeah yeah i'm not
playing that system again until um they
come out with some good games so overall
you know as far as people talking about
oh this is the best launch for a
playstation y'all don't y'all never had
playstation y'all knock fans um
you know i was dead from the original
playstation came out with ridge race and
all that stuff
y'all not even going to sit here and try
to act like uh battle arena to shendon
and only
talk about it talk about it jumping
flash
you you you you flashing the pan-ass
dudes
this is not it you got two games bro you
got you got demon souls and you got you
got spider-man then there's a dlc
spider-man's on ps4 nobody exactly so
you can't say this is the best console
launch it's not fair but can we at least
say
better
console launch games period so this is a
decent thing for people that were
looking for something particular so if
you're looking for something particular
that's all you got that's all the
capping is going to stop it's going to
stop here and it's going to stop now
this is not the best generation for them
and as far as failure this is the first
time that i've seen a console launch
with the level of failure rates that's
going on in in the business
fair enough i would just say the last
question it's just that we can we at
least say from a first party standpoint
they have a little bit more offerings
than series x which
oh yeah of course of course if
if if you want to if you want to do it
like that we can play this game let's do
this all right let's do it all right so
demon souls is the only game they got
right
that's it okay and so they got the party
back
they got one game that the series x
doesn't have at launch
okay then you're gonna say bright
infinite so i'll put a bright infinite
against your demon souls 7.99 that is so
disrespectful
it is but you know what we're putting up
one game that they got in one game again
david souza is recognized as revered
classic sir
he recognizes whatever it's going to be
i didn't know
i didn't buy it so it didn't register so
it didn't not
in the bushes okay
your you know theory should be enough to
say that the law of superiority
my playstation 4 for that leave me alone
i mean he's not wrong he really is
no light out here son no light there's
no light out here ain't no love okay
oh no
let me know hold up yeah i got something
this is the first time you've seen
failure right this eye did you forget
about the 360 king
red ring of death wasn't when they
launched how about that
how about that red ring and death didn't
happen until six seven months in and
then was like oh my god after we've been
playing it to death it wasn't day one
you didn't get home and like oh god red
ring of death
no
he literally didn't even have two days
of playing and then chris was like
why is my jewelry going
no
this is literally this is the equivalent
of starting your car and your engine
shut off
that's a brand new car you're like yo
what the hell is going on with it yo cog
if this happened to your range rover
you'll become arranged on the phone come
get this crap right now
you know the thing about that too is the
red ring of death
they immediately knew what that was
right that was a heat issue a heat sink
issue right no one knows what the hell
is going on with these ps5s we don't
know yeah we don't know and the issues
are are different like you said there's
different things going on that could be
software or hardware or both yeah um
it sounds like these crashes are related
to the data stream
that integrated ssd could be problematic
just my opinion then we got the gaming
forte dps podcast he said the xbox
series x and playstation 5 are here
can't wait for that destiny 2 patch in
december yes sir astro bot has no
business being this good word flat happy
boring day cog thank you brother today
we celebrate you bro please enjoy your
day thank you bro so i do i do have a
quick uh
in the honor
of
this xbox series x and the ps5 i think
i'm going to give away a game to the
members in the chat yes please i just
want the first member to tell me who won
last year is bend your knee video game
awards out of the lords
i will toss you a code in your dms on
twitter salute salute you already you
got to be a member to use it thank you a
lot for the happy birthday look i made
quick oh i'm going to be going along you
know same thing you guys saying um the
good for me obviously miles was was
amazing like king said so new york so
you know just good to see the
representation so i'm a big fan of that
um i'm with astrobot though dual sense
is a game changer for me you know i'll
be honest i was in the camp prior when
people were talking about it of like oh
it's gimmick and that or not until you
play it and like you're in the little
monkey suit and you're grabbing it off
and you're doing the thing and i'm like
i can't believe i'm liking this and i'm
like didn't the beat is coming on like
the gpu and all this stuff stuff and i'm
like yo this is fun and then it's like
it's such a love letter to everything
sony even when you have all the
different consoles and yeah you know
what i'm saying it really they did a
fantastic like when i heard about the
game as a pack-in i'm like i'll be
honest i'm like yeah whatever like i'm
not gonna play it and shout out to
requiem because he got me to play but um
when i did i had a lot of fun i actually
tested
the microphone with the controller in
party chat and it actually was not that
bad it just just the volume of who
you're talking to coming through your
controller is a little lower i think
that's gonna be an issue it may be but
it'll be flipped because i feel like
like imagine all those people
that
is it automatically turned on the moment
you unhook it or do you manually turn it
on in the settings you can there's
literally a button underneath the
playstation button to actually mute it
so you can mute the microphone so that
they don't they don't hear that kind of
thing i feel like a lot i feel like
you're going to get into like i mean
people don't really do public tracks
like that anyway most people are in
parties but
you're going to have that like you know
like when you go into into multi-players
with like rainbow stick season stuff
there's always that one dude that has
all the background yeah yeah it might be
that way i'm just like i just feel like
you're gonna see that more now but the
thing is the cool thing what i like
about their party chat system whatever
they call a group thing
i feel it's more control over party chat
more control over each individual i
think the setup of that in the ui has
really improved i like the social aspect
better because i've never been a fan of
their social aspect right it's like in
previous iterations of you i don't i've
never felt
sony took the social aspect as serious
as xbox does when it comes to departure
yeah so for me again shout out to
raqueno he was the first person he saw
multiplayer isn't their strength right
but i feel like now
they are taking it more serious with the
way the options are presented with the
ui it is do you think call of duty did
that to them because when they got call
of duty back they really started
prioritizing group chat and and chat
in-game functionalities more i've
noticed that
they expanded the party chat limit too
yeah expanded the limit you know
obviously we know they have the license
with that i want to shout out the
pathless a little hidden gem it wasn't
what did you buy that yeah bought that
off come on that's gi joe ninjas jinx
i remember you capping and i remember me
yeah yeah yeah yeah i know he was gonna
be all over you
wasn't gonna buy it
but he bought that so he ain't ever
gonna oh no i'm please shut up
dick
because he would scare the king it's
different than what i thought yeah king
only put pressure on me with ghosts and
shiva yeah i go for eyes like i'm
finishing this game i'm never gonna hear
it um but the whole thing is for
pressure but the thing is um it's
different what i thought i thought it
was kind of like just open platform and
maybe a little stealth it's really not
that it's no it's
oriented you gotta get the arrow you're
maintaining this constant speed
and then she's got the movement and
stuff like that it's cool and i will say
that the world is kind of those worlds
that i like those where the game doesn't
really hold your hand like another world
you know what i'm saying like you got to
figure things out kind of thing so shout
out to that it is actually i'm not going
to say it's next-gen looking you know
i'm saying it's an indie style it's like
the falcon here because i want to buy
the pokemon it's any but i got i got to
say like i was impressed with that and i
did some back compat and i just want to
shout out um
tekken 7 was impressive 60 um you know
really look good
um
days gone oh my god days going is a
whole different game right so okay
question oh good did you get the
streaming one or dude dude i did
so basically you have the playstation
collection now i didn't cop days gone
when they beginning so it was so cool to
that i got playstation you know plus and
i seen it on the collection and
downloaded that bad boy the collection
is lit no i'm telling you right now they
got that they got okay well i'll say i'm
gonna get the
whenever i'm able to log in that's
probably one of the only games
older games that i really wanted to play
that i said i was going to wait for the
playstation 5
place i'll tell you right now that's 60
frames hit different with that game now
the only thing though at first i thought
it was still rolling the playstation 5
controller the bike i shot they told me
it's the game
they have the worst bike mechanics i've
ever seen in traffic it's terrible oh
okay okay thank you because i thought it
was aims i thought it was so bad
that i would slightly tap the controls
and the bike is flying all over this i'm
like what is going on so i your base i
never played days going so i'm thinking
yo the dual sensor is just too sensitive
for this game no no
it's been bad since day one yo the bike
mechanics are horrible but shout out to
the 60 and the rest of the game looks
phenomenal and the last thing i'll say
goes to sashima good lord good lord at
60 frames a hit different and then on my
own land i'm seeing beads of sweat down
the character i'm seeing things i didn't
see i'm like yo this is crazy so yeah
shout out to them um last night i got to
get to the bat real quick
in my opinion now that i've had both i
don't feel the loading as as fast as
what i thought it was going to be not
that it's slow it's better than a
regular hard drive but playing coming
from the series x i felt like
things were zippier you know what i'm
saying and um that's the user interface
though yeah we got to talk about the
storage um some weird designs when i i
was downloading miles morales it's given
me the option to download the ps4
version and i'm like why i got yeah i
don't want that just give me telling me
to what i'm on you know what i'm saying
and um
that yeah attic mentioned this is my own
fault you know what i'm saying but i
assume
my dumb self thought that because i had
psn and i had cloud saves
that it was automatic and what so i
i factory reset my playstation 4 before
oh no
so i traded my joint in so i'm like yeah
playstation five i got ps down let's go
all my sayings ghosts deceivers finished
i got a platinum on i'm ready for new
game plus no you're not
no you're not oh damn no oh that hurts
you gonna start from the beginning
because you were supposed to manually
upload this is not xbox you gotta
manually upload i have the same issue
right now right all i wanna do is just
log into my playstation network and just
download my games over i gotta start
um the last of us two again i gotta
start a ghost of sashimi from the
beginning
that is the only playstation game i've
platinum
what year are we living in ain't bro
what is this i make that argument all
the time
let me make sure i'll be crazy with
their lack of application design man
it's bizarre to me like it looks like
you're going to get a cell phone and you
know your joint is supposed to transfer
over just boom just put the cord and
boom or you just uh you know you sold
your phone you got the new one and you
just log into your google yeah and
nothing shows up
what the hell is this i lost
it's their entire like ecosystem design
it's just not there like i made this
argument to someone else like i went to
do a screen screenshots like crazy from
demon souls and i just want to pull them
up and share them right not you can do
it through twitter on the ui
other than that you can't get them
unless you want to stick a usb drive in
i'm like my friend's like it's easy man
just put them on usb i'm like dude this
isn't 2005. why am i putting stuff on
usb drives transfer because if i was
like come on why don't you just add look
i come from the xbox ecosystem when you
have like it said it had it supports
cloud saves and i enabled it on my ps4
so i again yes it's my fault for not
doing extra diligence but i assumed that
it was it would automatically upload
into their cloud
we are coming from a different level of
air
okay we're coming from highfalutin
so when we come down and mess with the
peasants we don't expect that you know
to be mud on the floor on the rail on
the road it's ridiculous yeah i know you
know a lot of the chat i don't know
exactly how it works i'm assuming it's
manual uploads but if it's not you
definitely correct us in the comments
section but like look like on xbox and
this isn't all like console war stuff
but it's just there like you don't have
to do anything i've had like at least
three co if i wanted to go under my
brother's right now just sign into my
xbox and play it on there i don't have
to do any kind of manual but i do want
to say something real quick yeah we have
a lot of codes and i need to get rid of
a lot of them
so so if you if you have two if we have
250 likes on this podcast i'll drop a
code in the chat no doubt but look at
the other day it didn't automatically
download and i have i checked the
setting on the thing now strangely
enough on the ps5 they now have this
setting to say do you want your game
saves to automatically go to the cloud
so clearly they have something now in
place they must have realized the issue
because that setting never existed on on
playstation 4. no with ps5 they're
making on their back-end infrastructure
they're making a hard cut the new yeah
to new you know infrastructure
essentially which is long overdue yeah
um but uh yeah it's frustrating man i
just
xbox years ago and let's be honest they
have microsoft right
so they have that power to just your
profile on xbox is whole holistic right
it has your games your saves your
platforms it's all one
sony doesn't have that yeah real quick
pixel bit g said from your primary
console if you have psn your files are
online like so is that the same way that
like i assume that's how people share
digital libraries over there
is making someone else's stuff their
home correct yeah similar
so
if if i'm making someone else's my home
is my stuff not going to upload like
that makes no sense i'll just continue
anyway look
we're going along any at the end of the
day that and obviously like king said
we're not going to ignore the elephant
in the room right now is the crashing i
i i'll be honest i thought it was not
i'm not saying that it wasn't real i
just thought it was like you know
antidotal i didn't think it was isolated
isolated right until it happened to me
and strangely enough
my thing was weird because it wasn't
during the game when it happened for me
i had safely
shut down my system into rest mode i
always you know do interest mode and
then i remember i was like oh i want to
do something later and i came to boot it
back up and i'm like yo it's not
powering on what's going on so i start
freaking out like yo why is my joint not
powering so then i like you know
unplugged put it back then i seen it
then it came back and they got that
whole rebuilding the whole thing again
so look i don't know if it's tied
directly to wrestleman i just can speak
to myself this is going from ps4
i've always had issues with rest mode on
on playstation
i've had times where it's supposed to do
a firmware update or games download in
the back as soon as let's say i don't
play my playstation for a couple days as
soon as i come to boot it up it's
booting up into a rebooting and
rebuilding database your playstation was
not shut down so there's clearly
something in the way they're handling in
my opinion
background downloading and system
firmware updates that it doesn't
when i do that on xbox
yeah when i do that on xbox is the
difference like either the system's
already updated by the time i've you
know in that idle state
or when you do turn it on it's like yo
we're ready for an update fam you know
what i'm saying and then you go but
that's the thing and i'm worried if
that's the case here because i'm seeing
a lot of people with this problem but
that's what i got
anyway um or caught up with the the
chancellor addict because we got a
movement yeah i don't see anymore i
think i've seen on pixel bit oh shout
out to mazda you did miss oh i'm sorry
yeah we did miss a couple um uh uh all i
see is the cause i can't go up here
that's a perfect shogun beyond light
grind in full effect drop some stasis on
that like button no doubt freeze that
mods gaming you already know poland in
the house to the oh man thank you
brother happy birthday car great show as
always thank you brother much appreciate
it lawsongamer.net shout out to mods and
then um pixel bit g two dollars have a
chat no dudes check your online saves
manual download yeah that's what that's
what i heard too supergav87 salute with
the five pound i'll be playing xcloud at
work tonight so when i get home i can
just carry on where i left off on my
series x you can't beat that yeah that
is a fact man look we got to move up i
can't wait for that medium to come out
no me too man yes me too i want to
combine the last two topics basically
series x will finish it off and your
favorite games you know what i'm saying
as far as the um you know both consoles
so clowns i'm gonna set it up with you
because i don't need to have a
playstation so let's get you going xbox
series x just you know what stood out
for you now that you've had time with it
and your favorite uh games for it
well i gotta say uh right now my
favorite game on xbox series x is it's
an older game rec fest uh it loads super
fast and i love it i'm not having any
like frame dips i did on the one x or
any jitter and it just runs like butter
smooth even off and usb external
uh the other thing too that i'm actually
starting to like uh cognito and you
might have to help me out with this one
is destiny 2. welcome home i'm starting
to get into it
what is nice
gonna need your help on that one uh
don't get cog started man
i'm not i'm not touching this
i'm not touching that console to
december the 8th it's not that bad
though
it's still not that bad it's not that
bad but but i played all yesterday in
the day before i see you guys it's
beautiful and i ain't doing none of that
breen stuff down on pc to be able to go
on xbox like forte does
i just won't play on on xbox until it's
on the pc version yeah
he wants to join us kai you know he does
he does uh watchdog join you i used to
be there
let clowns get his balls off
um watchdog legion man i'm really
obsessed with this game and i'm like a
10 out of 10 on this one so yeah i'm
i'm like stuck in this and then you know
um i got into community game night that
tushy was doing yesterday was uh it was
like 10 people assassin lupa and a lot
of other people in there uh we were
playing forza horizon 4 and man
oh
that loaded so quick yes no
issues with load times at all
just that some people got to understand
how to join a convoy that's it but other
than that
it was great man so every every game i
throw on this series x is just beautiful
it doesn't matter if it's optimized or
not it just loads
like it should
no issues yes yeah yeah man enough
fantastic experience to be getting a
game about choice 20 i'll super chat
happy birthday cog thank you brother and
much respect to the lords i am loving my
series x but having issues with watch
dogs legion saves i lost 10 hours
because of save issues wow
that sucks
i haven't had that issue um i know that
there was
there was like a wee hour with a lot
yeah oh yeah there's a a weird glitch
there was a mission glitch but they
fixed that like two three days yeah
i had it
in watch dogs legions where like my
audio completely left and like i didn't
have no audio it didn't i hard reset
didn't matter it took like i think
there's a patch that came out a couple
days later because i had it before
launch that fixed it but it was just
like i couldn't play it without the
audio
yeah real quick klaus i'll give it right
back to you then jd gamer uh foster is
looking spooky over here for me i was
sad i couldn't get the playstation 5 for
launch days but now i'm thinking maybe
i'll wait too many parts look if you can
get it get it that's my thing but
continue clowns as far as your
experience and then your top games
yeah i think the you know the the
biggest issue that people were having is
that sometimes you're in the middle of a
game on the series x and then you get
like an update and then it takes you out
of the game and then sometimes it might
feel like it's glitching the game but
it's really not it's just a matter of
where you actually installed the game
and i think jess gordon had an article
on windows central on how to fix issues
like that so shout out to him
i think that's more of a game developer
issue than an xbox issue on how they
transfer the information back and forth
through the series x yeah
no doubt no no and you're just you're if
you have to rank them i just got to get
you out of here wave you got to rank
them like what's the top three games for
you
watch dogs legion number one
uh wreck fest number two
and i would go
ac valhalla number three okay got van
halen here first mansion no doubt no
doubt let's get uh my man aims man so
now like i said impressions and get top
three now that you've uh got a lot of
time with it
yeah series x uh really really
impressive uh i think what benefited
xbox here besides all the obvious things
we discussed is how they've been
iterative right so we came into day one
with that ui being
battle tested do you know what i mean it
wasn't a brand new thing that millions
of people were testing on day one we
already knew how it worked and it was
going to let me ask you a question about
the ui would you rather a new ui or just
this ui that you know knows going to
issues because i think that's one of the
reasons that xbox didn't lose no
features going to next gen is because
they if we're using the same ui would
you rather that or a fresh new eye like
playstation done because i don't think
so there's some give and take with both
of those yeah i agree with the addict
personally for me i love the iterative
design right because they're always
improving
um and they're they're learning they're
making it better now you can answer in
the chat if you guys want
yeah i do get the argument of you turn
it on and it feels it doesn't feel new
right i get that argument because for
generations now we've had something new
every launch we're in a different era
now man um it's they're way more complex
there's a lot more that goes into we're
seeing some of the things with the ps5
ui being new where there's issues or
missing features right we don't have
that problem on xbox because they've
been updating it along the way so i get
the argument of not feeling brand new
but i also i'm a functionality guy
everything i know and love and need is
there and it works so
that's my personal opinion top three i'm
gonna get you out
yeah yeah yeah series x um let's see so
i'm glad clowns called out uh legion i
love legion i've reviewed it uh i love
that game it's a really really strong
game so definitely check that out if you
haven't uh that's up there valhalla is
definitely top two i think i think i
have a top two and i already said it
which is valhalla and um demon souls
uh so i'm playing valhalla on the series
x it is absolutely stunning uh i take i
don't get anywhere because i take a
screenshot like every 10 seconds
uh let me shout out i got to do it for
chad i got to do it for king tetris
effect
play it it's i know it's tetris even if
you don't like tetris it's it's
incredible and it has a three player
co-op mode that wasn't on the um
it wasn't on the the ps4 version with vr
um
it's so much fun if you get two buddies
and you're just playing three player
co-op against the the um
the computer yeah i even saw jess posted
he's like buy 500 console play tetris
i'm like damn right you know what i mean
like i saw jason's tweet yeah yeah it's
that good you run after me a little
weirdo
uh and the only other thing i'll shout
out i was playing is observer uh redux
which is a blooper team game like medium
like uh blair witch and whatnot they
enhanced it for next gen it's really
really sharp um if you like those crazy
blooper team games
um but demon souls and valhalla are one
and two fart away from me no doubt man
strong strong list man lord attic man
now you had time
series x and then i need your top three
i like the series x i don't really have
no issues like i said um you know
so i got the x and i hooked it up and uh
my mom came over from her boyfriend she
was sitting on my bed
she's going that's your new car so i'm
like yeah she's like why does it look
exactly like the other one
yeah and i was like you know i
understand like if my mom can see
something like that definitely other
people can't though but it's just like i
i like the ui i don't really have an
issue with it and you know it is a
saying if it's not broke don't fix it
but obviously there's some cool
refinements especially when you hit the
guide button i love how things are
organized on the bottom part of the
guide it's very intuitive you now get
your notifications you got your store
you got i don't know i just like the
little nuances there but they definitely
rebranded it it's not the same ui that
was in there a couple months ago right
uh if you're in the preview program
you've seen this for a couple weeks or
at least a month yes the store
especially like they gotta copy the
playstation store low-key
but
as far as games yeah
what's your three what's your top three
that's rocking
i had to give
let's go uh let me thank you
my probably i'm not going to put them in
order
uh probably one of them is stated the k2
because i because the game just runs so
good it's unreal nice like and i feel
like if the game would have came out
running like that
it wouldn't have so much bad areas with
it yeah
um besides the tree front hall but that
game is amazing
and i'm looking at my games now i have
to give borderlands three like wow i've
been playing orderlance
borderlands got a series x patch yeah
and oh it runs so smooth like it's
probably the most impressive patch i've
seen on the platform nice nice let me
get jonathan b the super chat that went
up follow some chat i don't know about
y'all but my series x has been hot
boxing gonna be crazy when microsoft
starts drug testing your system to get
game updates what
here we go shout out to court
counteristic find out some chat cog i
need your help regarding destiny i'm an
xbox ambassador should i share my gamer
tag here absolutely if you want or you
can message me on twitter at lordcognito
in the dm you already know yeah if you
don't feel comfortable you don't get all
those messages yeah message me in the dm
that's fine gamer by choice follow super
chat i am loving legions except for save
issues what makes it unplayable i
brought ultimate edition and asking for
money back wow a lot of issues looks
like going on there let's get the king
in man now that you have been rocking
and rolling for a bit with that series x
and your top three
okay well one um the last time we did a
whole uh interface uh switchover we lost
netflix and everything so
um
that was really idiotic uh going from
the 360 to the xbox one
you know what's crazy king how bare the
xbox one was it was terrible like they
didn't have uh the friends list didn't
pop up like you know every friend popped
up none of that nothing everybody has a
revisionist history and forget exactly
what really went down
so um
the switch from 2013 to now
it's a group of individuals that love
you yeah
because they knew exactly what was wrong
and he did not repeat the same mistakes
now watch phil's interview shout out to
phil dominus maximus who really is
spencer
um
i watched his i watched his video and he
said he wanted a halo he wanted a halo
bag
he wanted a halo for launch and he knows
and i feel i feel that but brother um
you know being that i didn't get a
chance to you know salute you and we
didn't have ie3 talk uh this is a 10
brother
this is the 10 you
you your team your team goes by you
uh
this is a 10. like from
from the implementation
of the ui changing because i remember
when it was changing
before the console launched and then the
console launched and then i was doing
quick resume before but didn't know what
i was doing because it was popping up on
my screen but i didn't understand
what it would be when i had that ssd
inside
and now that i have all of these
functionalities everything is in place
you you know you built this house and it
was ready addy keeps talking about um
state of decay the wildest thing was i
put on state of decay my son came
running down the steps
to see it now i got to give sovereign
his respect because sovereign hates when
i was making my tv brute force things
yeah right so when i was no man
we didn't talk about it
when i was playing xbox one x i would
have to uh put that the fake hdr on
and i would have to um put this is the
brute force mode to boost my tv to put
every game damn near 60 frames it'll
force it
i took that off
with the series x
dear god
dear
god crazy so i'm i'm playing destiny so
so the first first state of decay that's
one
pub g
didn't trap upgrade yeah
oh i need to try it man i need to
trigger that is what
i suffered through hell with public
remember you'd be playing mid game and
it would just stop yeah you have to
reload to keep playing yeah that's
that's that's sacrifice
me brad we got stories
and um brad uh go go back and play
i put it on and i said dear god i just
it was a moment i said dear god and i
got killed but it was dear god
sleepy god said don't play that dear god
game king it's terrible
you're crazy so all right so
and then
gears tactics
whoa
you over there talking y'all didn't
nobody's talking about gears tactic
y'all keep talking about gears 5 but you
ain't throw that gears tactics
um
get them
you don't want next gen
but keep talking about two three games
like like stuff is happening this is
what happens when the media controls
your views and what goes on for you
put on
the gears tactics and i defy
you to come back to me and tell me
that's not next-gen
because that pc was doing that
but that xbox one x couldn't do that
so the series x
is definitely on one so i'm taking a
step back because i only got three
because i definitely always do tetris
and i think tetris is god body fat um i
saw you play so
my playstation 5 um
the user interface on the playstation 5
it doesn't make no never mind to me
what i didn't like with the playstation
4 was everything was hold up wait a
second hold up wait a second click a
button
wait a minute timeout
that's gone yes
so now i can jump from
game to game
and um i can uh zip around excuse me
that's my cough um but
it's better
so
over a period of time they're going to
fix
hopefully
whatever is going on
with the system
but
it's
better yeah
you know and um that's all i ever asked
i all i ever asked is it to be a little
bit more zippier right a little bit more
uh a better a little bit more refined it
looks like the same thing to me so i
really can't tell you all my friends
because i'm not i don't care to talk to
nobody over there i don't care for none
of that
i'm i'm there for the single player
triple a bangers that i play in the
corner by myself and i'm one and done
and i'm out of this
is is going to see a girl that you don't
want to see but you guys here because
you gotta see her for that period of
time when she come through and then
after those eight hours you should get
up out of there and go right back to
your real life
all right soon so the hell with the
hotness
she's just hot once a year when she
comes through
but other than that
it's it's i and and the dual sense
controller if you if
it feel great if it feels great it's the
best playstation controller period i
don't care what nobody say
um they do need to shave this down
because it's gonna hurt you're gonna
start with the cut
watch your
fingers anyway so that was what was your
three just to recall i only got one game
so miles morales miles morales and
another order of miles morales right
okay you said what was your your series
x before i move on oh um gears tactics
pubg
and state of decay oh um i didn't buy
any games
because uh black friday
two for two is on black friday guys
target and gamestop yeah is the stores
that you want to look out for
please make sure that you wait before
you go out and wasting all this money
because you can buy and all the new
games is going to be buy two get one
free or buy two get two free
so just take the time out just don't go
crazy just one week that's all you got
to do is wait and i'm going to get
valhalla and all these other games and
then i can talk about those lately
right now i'm not wasting that money no
doubt can i see you sneak back in i just
need your top three i don't know if kids
stood it i seen him jumping
okay um so easily for i don't have a
whole lot of games for playstation or am
i combining them or is it one
i mean no no actually three for each
that's what i would probably okay yeah
all right so
obviously the astrobot is the pack and
everybody has it i suggest you try it
right um spiderman miles morales um
giving you that both that fidelity and
60 frame that option um i haven't played
it yet
um but um based off the meta score i
guess you have to go demon souls
obviously that's those are the
the top three for the playstation five
and i and i should be getting my
demonstrations from jensen like next
week so gosh shout out to chance forgive
to help the whole community continue
yeah
xbox wow this is stuff
so
obviously my goddy contender assassin's
creed valhalla
um it's it's one of yo it's too big
that's solving here because i know when
you're gonna be going in yes i'll be
going bro
he yeah this is this is that work
um
the other game i'm going to say
for xbox uh that you would uh
should uh definitely that's in a top
three
uh what was the other one that i've been
playing i also like i said
you want something like arcadia you can
i'm gonna just go i'm not gonna go with
the the games that they re-optimize
right um but i'm gonna say uh
go ahead do dirt five
i gotta get it now man you guys are
getting excited i gotta get it
it's
i i i didn't i went into the game
because i was like i got forza horizon i
really don't really care to play this
um but i went in there with that expect
with that expectation and everybody
dogging it and they'd be like oh i did
not expect this so
definitely dirt five and then um
geez attic what game was i playing on
these i thought i was cycling
right now
i'm also
currently playing
black ops cold war and that campaign is
fire um yeah i'm getting that on friday
the game looks dope
i know it's a crosstown game but like um
but i'm saying this right now because i
have not yet
believe it's not i have not yet played
gears five on series x yet have you
played gifts
you hurt yourself
yet yeah
like there's so there's these handful of
games that haven't touched like i've i
jumped into sakura and i was like oh i
might be much better this time
yeah but uh those are it and honestly
you asked me this question next week is
probably gonna change but assassin's
creed valhalla expect that to be at the
top because it's right now right now
currently
it's it's my daddy oh no there's you
gotta it's your guys shout out to
scrolling dan uh two out of canadian no
top three yet but that cx has still been
the king yes sir that cx is fired god
let you already know aims i never got
your playstation three i think
yeah well sad thing is i'm only playing
three games on playstation so you gotta
uh elder scrolls sack boy and astro but
uh definitely shout out to astrobot
don't sleep on it yeah we already said
that yeah um and if you like platformers
like i already said if you like
platformers 3d platformers don't sleep
on sac boy i know it looks cutesy but
it's it's a good game factual fashion
look i make mine quick as far as my xbox
experience
uh quick resume the feature i didn't
think i would need oh yes quick resume
man i mean it is when you see that
little quick resume come up in that
corner for a game and you just write
exactly where you paused and left off at
it's the feature i didn't realize i
needed it it is game-changing it's truly
transformed i feel it's a next-gen
experience um i joke that i uh i can't
even pick up my phone anymore yeah like
yeah remember when you can look at the
loading screen no no it's a habit right
like you click a button and you pick up
your phone and by time i pick it up it's
already there and i'm like all right you
know like
yeah it's amazing absolutely so i gotta
shout out that king you said the words
out of my mouth you know everyone's
talking about you know the first part of
offerings i get it
but people acting like gears tactics
don't exist and if you play it
listen i'm gonna say something i'm gonna
say something spicy
splash damage or combination splash
damage coalition in my opinion
the cinemas in that game
blow away gears 5. i don't know what
they doing with gabe diaz and his
animation and everything else i don't
know what's going on even from the title
screen when you see the characters just
sitting there before you press the
button it pops off the screen and that's
un unreal engine 4 just like them
yo it's it's phenomenal and then for
people who's like yo but this pc is the
same thing here's the thing it's not
they added a jack mode
they not only that they've added new
enemies new mechanics you know what i'm
saying it is a thousand times
even if they said it's pc
you know regardless to what that's what
microsoft wants you to play at right but
at the end of the day so yeah you can
play it wherever they tell you to play
at and just get over there and play it
just just just because you know one
console
can't do it don't don't don't
be derogatory to the other one because
they have pedestrians i'm sorry look at
the end of the day it's going to be a
whole generation of console guys that
never played it and i really bro it's a
game pass give it a shot that game
i know tactics games aren't for everyone
rts i mean turn based but it's one of
the best and it's really done and he's
he's the last thing should have happened
right it's so satisfactory bro and they
got the best boss fights you'll ever see
in the turn base it's a story everything
is on point high quality aaa production
story and cinematics you're getting
prequel gear it's really good anyway 120
hertz games
amazing
didn't notice it until i felt like
competitive stuff i shall put rainbow
six season i'm trashing that game
i'm gonna tell y'all right now that 120
bro i was moving a second i was killing
it i was getting wet i got i gotta point
this out before we close out what's up
tell me how this man kiss move put on
the suit for spidey that uh the one from
spider-verse that half's the frame rate
because they wanted to appeal more to
the movie itself and he went on to
understand that the game was bugged you
didn't know the suit did that oh my gosh
the game was bugged i said that i
thought the frame that emotion you was
you you was clouded
no like you weren't clowning i wasn't
clowning the person no still stuck with
frame rate that was hashtag playstation
five you should see all the tweets
though like what happened well we'll
talk about this afterwards yeah we're
talking about looking yes
you'll defend yourself please don't say
we believe you we believe you look at
the end of the day that um i will say um
yo like addict mentioned
no man's sky y'all i haven't played in a
minute
and bro 4k 60 hit different
it is truly playable and amazing it's
kind of crazy what they've done with
that game yes yeah don't throw that on
and for me personally as far as the um
last point i say about the system
dynamic latency input is a change i do
feel the speed the everything with that
controller shout out to jason ron when
we had him on you know he mentioned that
i can't lie the ui the loading
everything is zippy everything just
feels much faster i have to say that um
as far as um the bad i got to mention
we got it they got to fix the sharing
clips on hdr or something it's something
yes it's very dark it's very i don't
know what's going on like they got to
fix that because these games look
beautiful you want to share them and
then you're looking at the shared joint
you're like yo why is it like i'm in the
you know some dark tunnel you know what
i'm saying and i gotta mention it shout
out to dealer game i know you mad at me
but i gotta say it
um
the download times y'all
i've never experienced this with xbox
one x i don't know what's going on i i'm
going to attribute it
to launch day launch week right it's
it's definitely on the xbox one x
because when i downloaded games on my
xbox one x and x i didn't think about it
i would just you know play and then you
get the little pop up it's done
i'm noticing games are taking longer so
i don't know what's happening and is it
just because it's a worldwide launch and
it's just you know so i'm going to test
it further to see but that's something i
know this game's taking really long you
know to do to do the download but that's
it and as far as my arm three yeah gears
tactics
gotta shout out yakuza like a dragon i
got a shout out and for me
a lot of xbox guys always complain
oh we don't get the japanese games oh
phil oh get out there and support
because at the end of the day this is a
game that's launching first on series x
and look it's wacky it's over the top
but it's fun it's crazy i'm having a
good time man i i want more of this and
i'm doing my um you know performance
mode on that joint and the last i
normally kill for this
bright memory man
look
screen tearing i get it
it's a glorified demo i get it
for yo
it's eight bucks it's made by one guy
all i'm gonna say is
it just shows you the potential
of what could be with the if with the
infinite that's going to come which is a
full game with him with a team you know
what i'm saying i just feel that what
he's able to do graphically what he's
able to do is cut i like his boss fights
i like the music look is the story
nonsensical and foolish yes
is it over the top yes but i think he's
got something
you know what's it and i think yeah just
give it a talk what's up [ __ ] no [ __ ] i
i agree with you i like i i was a little
bit embarrassed to be like i caught the
best
tell me you didn't notice a little bit
of you know souls
yeah and you're fighting the ball she's
like yo i can't shoot with the bullets
then you're doing the dash and you're
doing the sword
they look like they got a demon soul
first person joint going on
yeah i think he got potential with this
now i don't know if you notice though
just to give you a heads up though that
demo is the time full pc version time
at the end of the day yeah it is a
straight it's a it's a lazy part we know
it's just pc you're literally moving it
like a mouse over the joint well you
know look i understand the junk that's
all i'm going to say at the end of the
day check that out playstation 5
astrobot we already went ghost already
went and obviously miles and that's it
let's get the poll let's get about it
because it is we are crazy late as king
is saying so new ilp pope this week
shout out to jansen's kirsten with the
arrival of both next gen consoles which
next gen feature has impressed you the
most so the choices are a the entire
dual sense the feature set had back
feedback all the haptic feedback all
that b xbox series x quick resume
or d i'm gonna see i don't care y'all
ps5 is crashing all the time
x stay on fire those are the choices
please write the book when you come out
yo shout out to everybody came through
lord brat
lord angeli bowden lord kiss move lord
clouds three hour marathon i apologize i
got you guys super long let's get in
with ainsley a kid first let's get kid
cause i know he's working for work where
can the five people find you what you
got going on sir
find me on twitter at kiss food find me
on youtube back his move i got
um pretty much some console reviews to
do ps5 xbox um some game reviews i'll be
pointing out so it's going to be it
reminds me i got to make thumbnails
yeah yeah
that's it man thank you guys uh iron
lords man you guys have been awesome man
no doubt appreciate you man shout out
somebody's super chat bright memories
like souls crisis and millerstone i'm
with you man i think they own us
something i'm gonna hit them with the
horn or something so let's get um aims
man where can the fine people find you
what you got going on sir
yeah great times as always guys i
appreciate it uh just seasongaming.com
you can find all of our stuff there um
i'm porsha power on everywhere psn xbox
you know twitter and uh doing a uh just
got into streaming recently and working
through demon souls right now so uh it's
actually a good time yeah and kind of
sharing the experience with some people
so if you want to check out demon souls
you don't play those games but you want
to come hang out with just some chill
people and check it out uh find me there
that's porsche power as well so thanks
as always guys
thanks for rocking i know you've done a
lot of shows man again shout out to
bro i feel i feel so guilty i think i'm
attached to this chair
bro shout out to the big cash shout out
to your team man shout out to dan he's
always making me laugh we're trying to
do that latino oh by the way
make sure dan's trying to not buy yakuza
because he hates the turn-based stuff
give him [ __ ] oh i would give him
yesterday i got you i got you go get him
we go get him make sure you hit them up
everyone hit up danny i'm on everybody
that's not supporting yakuza because
you're always complaining
and now he's here ain't nobody buying it
okay
italian clowns man it's been a minute
brother four guys recordings by bro
man where can the five people find you
what you got going on man
hey man thanks for having me it's always
a pleasure being in the room man you
know goes back to the toys r us days
you know what i mean
um everybody can find me at italian
clowns and it's all social media and
four guys recorders we did an interview
with scott millard he's part of the
bluebird team of companies uh he is the
publisher for fear demick and i actually
have uh
three big interviews coming up i have
one with jim hyjel from ea
i have
uh jimmy palmiotti i don't know if you
guys are familiar with him but he is a
writer producer of film tv comics and
games writer harley quinn helped on dec
helped on the suicide squad movie and
harley quinn movie
um
and then
we might have somebody from
seattle washington but you know
exclusively pr
pr has to do their thing so hopefully
hopefully they
hopefully it passes and you know they
see that i'm a good dude and
you know i just hope so man but yeah
yeah four guys recorders all right first
of all salute to you clowns man you guys
been grinding for a minute salute to
your team i want you to shout out your
team you got what you got you got my boy
midway over there right you got well she
got over here let's go oh yeah man the
four guys recorders team is growing uh
we lost you know we lost about two
people but that was for the better cause
of four guys so now we got midway
monster we got vj we got flemish
uh who's been co-hosting the 4g qtv news
yes and
we also have mav fun speculations
yeah he's a really good dude and um
dreadpool just joined to become an
official crew member as well
and krispy baum is an honorary member
for interviews he can't join full-time
so
yeah so yeah so excited man just really
really excited also uh real quick before
i forget this shout out this interview
we did a litter interview with lucy i
can't say her last name because it's
very greek but dreadpool even spoke to
her in greek on the interview uh she was
a lead character animator for
battletoads yes
um and she is a really cool person man
just down the earth hey shout out to
your channel when you wake the fight
with time to get that rocking
uh tuesdays five to seven p.m eastern
usually and then the interviews we've
been trying to do at least two a week
i'm not giving up i'm gonna keep going
kug keep it going brother keep it up man
i appreciate you man thanks for coming
through i see midway mazda in the chat
throwing it up for the show that's
what's up and of course lord attic man
where can you find people find you man
you can find me on twitter lord addicts
iop you can find
you can find me on xbox series x i'm
about to download this dragon quest demo
i didn't realize there's a demo nice yes
i've been playing the hell out yeah so
i'm definitely going to play that uh
then you could also find me grinding
away my life away on destiny no doubt
salute to the grind you already know and
of course the return the triumphant
return of a healthy king
back oh what's the poster about what's
going on sir
oh wow this is this is it this is stuff
that's going to be littering my gaming
space that's classy right there that's
common stuff let's get it let's get it
well um
happy birthday thank you brother
you know um
it's just uh
it's kind of crazy man like
we old
we old man it's it is a beautiful thing
because you know uh being black and from
the bronx you don't get to get old
mm-hmm
so again uh i salute you
i salute that uh you're gonna have a
great night and
you know um i was able to you know
partake in your birthday today no doubt
um
so it's a it's a beautiful thing i want
to say thank you to each and every last
one of our panel members brad
agent flip-flop
shout out to you and respect to you
hyperbole is crazy over there
shout out to ames
man i'm gonna tell y'all right now boy
y'all you have to be thinking i'm joking
but if you ever listen to the one
percent talk then you're here one
percent works right so listen listen
listen y'alls y'all think i'll be joking
listen man you're out here doing these
wild things it's fantastic and this
utterly respect humble
one of the most humblest people that you
are ever gonna come across and i'm
definitely gonna watch your stream
because i'm not buying demon soul so i'm
definitely gonna do that
shout out to everybody
i appreciate that no i brought cracker
though i'm never doing that i'm gonna
watch this i'm gonna watch the hell out
of such a good game yeah uh kids
you are one of the most entertaining
dudes that i i i i really
i really love to watch i really do you
you are you are the best
we set up this demon souls challenge man
you won't want to throw in on this in
the chat we're going into nothing
um
but uh yeah uh oh yeah
you you gotta get your health up before
we start yeah yeah i'm not taking i'm
taking this i'll die today
yes please will be said is we're not
risking this at the expense of king's
health so we gotta wait
it's healthy first i'm not dying today
that ain't gonna happen
but uh my man clowns yeah i told you you
should have smacked that baby but um
but you didn't have to smack the baby so
you know you got your series x anyway
and you did it with you you know popping
the dude in the mouth for some pepperoni
pulse
and um
they respect you your hustle because you
came through and the goomba slid that
piece through the line
i was nervous
i was always going to get indicted the
way clouds was talking but continue
that's when he does it more tactful
very smooth with it too yes my bosses
you know give you pizza some people give
you blood oh it is what it is so
um
i love you guys absolutely uh and uh
i really wanted to be here with jason
ronald oh i'm gonna tell you right now
that level of work and
my belief and that that interview was
gonna happen i didn't care what cog
if you ever look at our dm's
and you know these dudes would be
talking something i mean shut up we win
it
it's gonna happen they'd be like i don't
know because they shut up
i'm good that's man of his convictions
and um
you know why is it
i i just feel that we keep it real with
you in fact so um even even if even if
you even if those 10 or 11 dislikes
there you didn't like anything that i
said at least you can say to yourself
well at least he ain't fraud and though
i'm gonna tell you
[Laughter]
i mean at least they be like you know
what i can't stand them but i respect
them and that's all i've asked you to do
so you know just you know like follow
subscribe and make sure that you share
because the algorithm is necessary for
us to even grow yes you know we have 400
people in the chat and if those 400
people just shared it out to 400 more
people then you know more people can get
a chance to see exactly what you're
enjoying what you have you know fun with
so please do that but i can't wait to
see you guys next week when i'm feeling
a little bit better and not you know
jumping in and out as much but um you
guys have a blessed day yeah and i will
see you guys next week yo salute
everybody like i said they came through
ames uh brad clowns it's been a minute
all you guys so love what you guys are
doing it's always fun to do these again
salute to the chat thank everybody for
the um happy birthday shout out shout
outs means a lot to me you know i'm
getting old so you appreciate them as
you get older look we got a lot of stuff
planned for on the month still some more
fun stuff cooking for the rest of the
end of the year look everybody enjoy
your sunday until next time we are out
of here peace
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
foreign